the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
S at the American Cup in St Louis
Challengers refuse to go down without a
fight forcing playoffs in each bracket
it was a repeat of last year in the
women's event with Alice Lee again
falling to reigning Champion Irina Crush
Wesley so gifted Open Bracket Champion
Cara Nakamura with his first loss can so
complete his comeback to steal the title
or does the Wiley veteran have one more
trick up his sleeve a new reign will
begin today who will rise to the
occasion and who will fall the final day
of the American Cup coming up next
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the final day
it's Championship Sunday here at the St
Louis chess club and we have just an
incredible match day for you it's Wesley
saw versus Hikaru Nakamura who's going
to take the title home let's go to the
studio and find out with Yasser and Joe
we welcome you to St Louis Missouri the
capital of Chess in America this is the
10th and final day of the 2023 American
Cup the championship rounds begin right
now from the St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome from the St Louis
chess club I'm International Marcy van
kahauska and has been a great pleasure
to be sat here commentating on this
scintillating event alongside the one
and only Grandmaster yes the Sarah one
Jovi All Good Things have to come to an
end I'm afraid this is it the final day
but it's been great with you and
Christian each and every day thank you
so much hello everyone and yes indeed
it's Championship Sunday and yes I am
dressed for the occasion we are all
dressed for the occasion as we're
representing the great state of Missouri
and the St Louis chess club where all
the action happens in this Grand finals
it's come down to this
one Wesley so versus Juan Hikaru
Nakamura because we already have a
champion in the ladies Jovi do the
honors yes uh hearty congratulations to
American Cup champion Arena Crush who
goes home with 25
000 as well as a 5 000 Championship
bracket winner bonus it's been an
absolute superb tournament she has just
proved her metal it's just been
absolutely wonderful to follow the games
and uh defending champion and today
however we're going to be crowning the
open Champion one of these two gentlemen
will call himself the American Cup
champion but who will it be who will it
be because after Wesley's comeback win
yesterday these two are on equal footing
and we have to definitely check out what
they're what they're going to be doing
and what are they going to be doing in
the playoff scenario that we have uh
for them yes they are playing a two-game
rapid playoff and it will be at a time
control of 25 minutes plus 10 second
increment now if the score is tied then
we're gonna go on to a rapid playoff or
for 10 minutes plus five second
increment if the match is still tied
after all that go to a blitz playoff and
finally you might love it you might hate
it but I personally love it it is my
favorite it's going to be decided by an
Armageddon game it is still tied after
six games my goodness and Christian
you're in studio to drill down and tell
us how these players match up in Rapid I
love the way you're representing the
club I mean you've got great tastes and
clothes I like the blue shirt I like the
red one as well I really love the one
Jovi is wearing right now but guys I've
had so much fun calling all the action
with you too so thank you very much for
a couple of weeks of exciting chess and
welcome to the championship Sunday here
at the Saint Lucia's club we have so
much amazing chess that big clash
between Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura we
also have a blitz tournament happening
in the next couple of minutes but let's
take a look at the head to head of this
big Titanic Clash that is about to
unfold here at the American Cup the
match between Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley
so take a look at that in red in the
rapid matchup they've played so many
times these players know each other so
well 21 wins for Hikaru 15 losses and 59
draws but I have to say in the rapid
matchup it felt like Wesley was the more
stable player in their two encounters up
to this point let's take a look at the
live ratings as we go into the final day
of the grand finals as we can see in the
rapid world rankings number 11 versus
number three as I was mentioning I feel
Wesley is the more stable player when it
comes to Rapid format but in the blitz
if it gets there and let me remind you
what happened in their first match in
this competition it was Hikaru who went
on to win a smooth Blitz player of 2-0
against Wesley so eliminated through him
to the elimination bracket but still
Wesley so like a phoenix rised back to
the top and right now he will be meeting
Hikaru guys what an amazing day of Chess
ahead of ourselves but tell us a bit
more about the the blitz tournament
that's about to happen well yeah indeed
we've got that going on we do we do have
the blitz tournament and we will be
bouncing back and forth from the blitz
tournament event which is being held at
the Chase Park Plaza Hotel and of course
the match between wesiso and Hikaru
Nakamura and there you see some of the
players getting ready for action and
what I love about this yeah just go down
some of those names
you know okay so top seed yep Fabiana
Carolina not bad the second seed Lavon
aronian also not bad
and then we can go down linear Dominguez
Sam Shanklin I mean it just gets well
let's put it another way you got to go
all the way to number 14 and I saw we
lost our very own version of Kobe and
Noir you know is uh he's not in the
truck anyway he's not in production but
bar one of the top Blitz specialists in
the United States he's really darn good
I'm spotting him there we go
we do have four Boards of action and
we'll be bouncing back and forth because
of course our primary uh game will be
the Wesleyan
and I was thinking and there we see
Wesley I was thinking as I was coming in
the studio today what is it that
separates these two players at the
moment well I'll tell you they've both
taken a measure of one another but
Hikaru won when it counted he got the
ten thousand dollar
Champions bracket uh bonus by winning
when he won and okay uh Wesley has
extended the match to today starts with
the black pieces and uh Christian uh E4
e5s
no no I think we're going to see
something else from uh Hikaru C4 English
he tried the C4 and he got some slight
Advantage uh I mean it's so difficult I
have to tell you Wesley in my opinion is
one of the most uncomfortable player to
get ready for in terms of opening
preparation because he knows absolutely
everything to Perfection every single
minute detail in the opening he will
know it and he's going to be ready for
it very very uncomfortable player with
Hikaru 25 minutes plus 10 seconds
increment he needs to put early pressure
on his opponent build up a time
differential and take it from there that
gov has been one of the things we have
seen about Hikaru is he has gained the
time on the clock but somewhere towards
the end
he fritters it away and they're become
even on the clock again very very little
between yeah I have to say yesterday
that was exactly the scenario
and we also saw Hikaru just burning time
in very tense positions not really
wanting to strike or to take anything
any concrete measures and there we see
the players getting ready I I kind of
agree with uh you Christian I think
Hikaru is angry he kind of expected this
to be over he doesn't want to be exactly
like
by the way just on that note uh he uh
Wesley said uh I like to play in The
Blitz tournament he didn't think he was
going to make it to today so when you
have that type of attitude whatever
happens today is just a great bonus it's
a bonus absolutely trying to shy away
from the main lines of theory with this
idea of Knight F3 and E3 this is not a
bad idea especially for a rapid
um playoff now this thing could
potentially develop into a very sharp
line if you try ideas of as we will see
later on C4 B3 get the bishop on the
long diagonal and then if black decides
to play with the move E6 which I'm
anticipating he will do that's one of
the top options in the position then
maybe and by the way detail C4 is a big
big move in this position he decided not
to allowing white to defend that pawn on
C4 with B3 now you can no longer take on
C4 because if you do that then you will
accept the worst position and do you
think Hikaru will be feeling so
aggressive that he might I'm seeing a
potential G4 yes oh you spell the words
right out of my mouth
is that a song from meatloaf yes
B3 okay let's see so we have been seeing
by the way in his streams that uh and
his uh rapid Blitz chess that Hikaru
loves these B3 Larson uh queenside fee
and Shadow so b2b3 and he sidestepped
the Queen's Gambit accepted that's
already a kind of success for ikaru and
what is it what else could uh he should
be seven okay that's a different
approach Bishop D6 is one of the main
lines and try to play in the center for
E5 now Bishop two E7 is a bit more of a
passive approach and it leads to this
type of thing
maybe isolated maybe hanging if you
decide to play P6
Knight to C6
you like it I do like it and white has
predominantly
develop the light squared Bishop there
it goes E2 Bishop Bishop E2 well also
through his own move order uh Wesley has
sidestepped the lines where the bishop
pops out to B5 when the king is still in
the center so Bishop to E2 and well
these are the type of positions where
you start before the
I want to say kind of a tarash where you
try to put your Bishop on F6 in order to
neutralize the fiangetta bishop so
Knight F6 would get my attention this is
the more testing move and he played it
he knows it and what about D takes
that's the main move it's the main move
yeah and now Bishop F6 or that's right
Bishop F6 and we have to play something
like Knight
that you have in the position
and from a theoretical point of view uh
how how do the how does what's the score
like when you get into these games and
we do see D4 it's fairly decent uh for
white especially if you go for this
bishopath six Rook to say I Rook to C1
Queen A5 Knight to D4 this is more or
less forced right you have C6 root yes
you have to defend that Knight on C3
somehow right and after Knight takes C5
we have Knight hd6 and we transition
into the
hanging parts right this type of
positions a wide scores quite well 62
percent
victories in this position 60 that's a
very decent result yes wow yes okay
at least according to my database and
I'm seeing a lot of very top level games
right nvl played it Wesley actually he
played this with the white pieces Magnus
Carlsen recently against England has
played this move as well so it's it's a
well-established line
and uh well the Hikaru is playing very
quickly I think we have a bishop F6 yes
just that whole line that you just said
62 62 percent after Knight to d uh
Knight to D4 Knight takes C5 and 1966
yeah these players know their stuff
right through this opening like oops
like
he knows it backwards and forwards but
so is uh Wesley right
both players Knight E4
Queen to C2
Wesley himself playing with the white
pieces against Judah as you've mentioned
Christian yes so if we take oh pardon I
apologize Jeffy I was just getting
curious if we take everything on C3
players are asking this very same thing
oh the first Wrinkle in the position
Queen Rook to C2 after Queen A2 is the
main move by far by far Bishop to F3 is
a novelty but right now that does invite
the move Rook B8 right
Rook B8 uh uh tickles the pawn on B3 the
B8 perhaps Queen takes C6 and Bishop
takes D5 those type of ideas is that
well that looks pretty darn it is it is
I mean you're playing for a very minimal
Advantage Even Stevens I mean four
versus four sorry yeah you think
something no no no I just wanted to
point out the the obvious I believe that
Rook B8 is the force because it was not
forced but it's very ideal because we're
okay one huge threat on the board
trapping the queen truly truly you don't
have time to play Bishop D7 Rook A1 and
partying with the lady Rook B8 however
doesn't I mean I I can't imagine
anything better than winning these two
pawns for a Pawn on B3 but that position
sure doesn't seem to promise much and I
was also going to ask the other question
what happens if instead of playing Rook
B8 you just simply play Queen A6
with the idea that you know what let's
go into an end game where I have two
weak pawns but do you have a really bad
Pawn on B3 as well are you gonna
everything everything is very very close
to you that looks I I can tell you that
much everything is very close to
equality and maybe in the best scenario
you will get the Rooks four versus Rook
3 right on the same side but which
everybody all these Elite Grand Masters
they know how to make a draw with their
eyes closed
and once played a match with vesely
Ivonne Chuck where I was white in the
first game and I got rook in four pawns
versus Rook on three same side of the
board he played it fantastically well
through the game
next game I was black
I got broken four versus Brooklyn three
the same side of the board and he played
it really well and Drew the game and now
we had to play the playoffs and I said
to him the seal if I get rook and four
versus rook and three that's three game
repetition
I'm gonna call the match and draw he won
the playoff
did you did you get a reckon I didn't
otherwise I could have drawn the match
and uh Wesley the move Bishop F3 uh
stopped Wesley in his tracks uh because
he was expecting that Rook C2 move was
Rook C2 the 62 percent
after Rook to C2 it's 50 50. everybody
Drew there everybody
but this begs the question why is Hikaru
chasing down this line why is he
choosing this because of what Wesley
said yesterday they simply don't have
time to find anything in between games
I'm telling you these guys know
everything right they know every single
detail in pretty much every single
topical line that and they've played it
so many times against each other right
they need some time in between games to
come up with new ideas
unfortunately obviously for them they
don't have that type of uh luxury right
because they're playing day after day
day after day so they need to find
something a wrinkle that's going to make
your opponent think for a few minutes if
he finds the best moves he's going to
make an easy draw if he doesn't then
you're going to be able to put some
pressure I was going to ask this
question about
um
AI for instance AI is so good these days
right is it possible for AI just to kind
of like look through these all the games
that the players ever played and kind of
says there's a weakness here there's a
weakness there can it kind of but I'm
not not in terms of statistics openings
and stuff I'm just talking about he
trades pawns Jovi if you find it or yeah
exactly sure you get me on board we've
got a coach right over there make sure
a 50 bill is burning in his pocket he's
ready to share he would have a sweet
multi-million dollar accident
[Laughter]
just call your GT on that note I wanted
to say that that's why so many chess
lovers look forward to the world
championship matches because in those
World Championship matches you have
three months six months of preparation
where they where they get together with
their teams and they really pour their
hearts and souls into their preparation
and come out with fantastic ideas so
World Championship matches were usually
like opening up the curtains to
innovative ideas because of exactly what
Christian has been saying between the
games
these fast-paced uh tournament games
they don't come up with the ideas they
don't have enough time to get together
by the way on that GT note seriously if
you put together a program that comes up
with how to play against the Karo Khan
how to play against the Queen's Gambit
accepted boy there's a lot a lot of
people like that and I lose my job as a
second
[Music]
as a commentator but it really wouldn't
be fun to kind of like have a like a
Bots kind of be your coach it would be
like you call up a number and it would
go play
Bishop Bishop F4 London opponent very
bad very bad yeah that's why I don't
reach for Perfection myself in the
commentaries because you know it would
be boring right exactly
bring that human element the touch that
Special Touch
um and if you're just joining us uh once
again tell our viewers what they're
watching oh we are in the midst of a
playoff between Hikaru and Nakamura and
Wesley so both of these players are on
their last lives which means that we are
now playing a two-game rapid match which
is 25 minutes plus 10 seconds and
whoever wins this well walked away with
fifty thousand dollars the championship
title and the honor the glory of being
the American Cup 2023 uh Champion uh
Wesley has been in a deep freeze uh
after this novel move Bishop F3 uh up to
this point the players have been
following the established theoretical
battles and they usually all went Rook
C2 the move Bishop F3 has literally
Frozen Wesley for a better part I'm
gonna say of eight minutes or so close
to 10 minutes yeah even closer to in a
rapid game of 25 plus 10. that could
come back to haunt him uh burning so
much clock this early and why
he sees something in the position that
he's afraid of why is he I don't think
necessarily this is something that he's
afraid of I think he's just trying to
decide on which path to choose because
as we were seeing Bishop E6 is a move
Rook B8 is a move Queen to A6 the move
that Jovi recommended which was played
right now after a long thing on the
board is a move as well so he was just
trying to choose what path maybe to
force the queen trade and perhaps this
is the most
practical and enforcing Hikaru trying to
recall his lines
just take the pawn I would also take the
pawn and we get this position where okay
I have a weakness a weakness and you
have one
and he's done Queen take C6 regaining
the pawn uh the best that Hikaru could
hope for in my estimation is four versus
three yes but with two Rooks he can play
a long while with a single Rook uh we
would expect that to be a draw Bishop E6
already on the board let me just refresh
my board to be what I was thinking of is
that you simply cannot win
one of those extra pawns sorry one of
those vulnerable pawns without trading
Rooks and if you are in Hickory let's
say you have this well well yeah I mean
for example you could go A5 A4 let's say
white trades
and then they start defending their that
D5 Pawn with all their might right
you're gonna have to see a trade of
Brooks you would probably see something
along the lines of A5
Rook C5 A4 take take on D5 and play it
four versus three right okay well I
might not be so compliant as to play A5
that's the most compliant yes could I
could I just like go much more directly
Rook B8 and Rook takes B3 by the time
you're gobbling this guy aren't I
gobbling this guy
let's put a move on the board shall we
okay one not that you're threatening to
take or do anything but hey Asic
and okay he played Rook to D1
immediately going after the pawn okay
let's try to find something uh that
gives black some problems I have this
idea I take on D5 you take on yes on D5
yes take take you take on B3 out with
the suit yes correct
the problem is right now I don't have
time to put one of the Rooks on the
seventh correct so this is kind of
annoying but let's just play Rook D7 and
you play a silly movie don't check maybe
or you play G4 and then you play a silly
movie don't you you defend a pawn from
A3
correct
this is after Rook to C7 this is the
most dangerous thing that you guys can
play I I would really maybe the table
bases say draw or whatever but I would
feel uncomfortable directly here if I
manage to get two Rooks on the seventh
right if I manage to do that even if
he's four versus four I can just push my
pawns yes towards E6 that e-pawn that
doesn't have an opponent on the E file
get it to E6 and try to open up the
seventh friend that is an end game I
don't want which brings me to Jovi's
point which is yeah you're gonna win my
Pawn but I'm gonna force a trade of
Rooks whenever you try to take the pawn
on D5 I want to make sure that
um the four versus three will be a
single Rook ending not a double Rook
ending and that makes a lot of sense
Rook C7 oh hold on we do have a move
Rook B8
D1 and then Rook B8
on the board and very quickly Rook see
seven so
Hikaru is inviting this for uh
four versus four
how are you but hang on a second there
are some back rankers here for both
sides yes
for both sides so think about but can we
go back just one move I'm not going to
take on A7 I'm going to go H3 or yeah
let's go H3
okay can I get H4 please sure sure
[Laughter]
we will meet your wishes H4
um anything you want why position is
now this one all right they say seven I
just can't imagine anything but a draw
Rook Rook Rook d8 uh Rook B8 Rook B5 I
mean you're gonna have to take on A7
someday I'll go rook d8 and H6 yeah okay
it's funny Jeffrey yes we were coming on
show you were showing me some positions
where H4 King H2 King G3 was the winning
sequence that's right well we can get
our King to F4 but are we really that
impressed by the way uh
um Wesley's not impressed Wesley's
saying
look I'm with Jovi on this one I'm just
going to trade one pair of Rooks and we
can we can call it a quick draw I like
it yes Rook takes B3 Rook takes A7 Rook
B8 current position with Rook B1 on
Black's agenda
um
okay so say for example Wesley gets that
beloved Rook trade Rook trade trades off
the Bishops and you have Rook versus
four Rook versus three pawns and look at
that he doesn't want to see that beloved
there are some constellations of uh
where it's actually very difficult for
the defending side tell me what you
would like again please Judy so from
this position he just played Rook A1 I
wasn't expecting Rook a Wonder so I was
expecting a kind of scenario where age
yeah then you're gonna take and then I'm
gonna go Rook here right
I'm in problems
because I obviously have problems the
the back rank so what we've seen instead
excuse me what we've seen instead is
Rook a A1
and then
Rook to B5 right Rook B3 to B5 just
defending the pawn because now you are
threatening to take it Hikaru is with
you a hundred percent he's played the
move H4 and Wesley said okay let me
bring my king quickly towards E5 so that
you can't play King F4 I can understand
if you get Rook D4 king of four maybe a
little plaster well this this is what
you were waiting for I'm thinking that
Hikaru is aiming for he is aiming for
that Rook four versus three yes but he's
aiming to do it when the pawn structure
is really good for white in the sense
that it's not easy for black to trade
pawns okay but how are you going to do
that that's the problem well he's put
his Pawn on H4 right on H5 and he's done
sure why he's he's done
uh by the way uh Christian is a hundred
percent right that uh oftentimes black
does play H5 very very quickly yeah this
particular case
what I like about
Wesley's play specifically here
is he's put his King on F6 because there
are times he might prefer H6 G5 to H5
the easiest way right now is to just go
Rook V6 yeah we play Rook B6 exchange
the Rooks give out the pawn on D5 and
play H5
uh what everybody knows how to make a
draw in that position uh apologies Rook
A6 yeah Rook B6 just give up the pawn
yes forget about trying to hold four
versus four just give up the pawn take
on D5 exchange everything put the pawn
on H5 you are 27.80 or whatever he is
right now you know how to make a draw in
this way exactly
and he's done it and he's put the pawn
on H5
yeah this is actually
it's funny I I was really lucky I had
had an early chess coach in my career
his name was Jeffrey Parsons He was
about a Class A player which is very
strong let's say 1900 but what Jeffrey
was was he just absolutely adored
studies and end games
and the end game studies uh you know he
enthralled me with and so I learned how
to win King and pawn end games before I
learned what the scholars make was yeah
I mean like what so yeah and four versus
three he said yes sir you know
uh these types of exams are like
cheating on an exam you know you're
going to get them and you know you're
going to get three versus two you know
you're going to get four versus three
you might as well learn them inside out
now so that when you get them at the
board you'll play them
perfectly well yeah
Okay so
just for the benefit of doubt you know
yes
how is it possible to draw this as black
what is the technique well and what is
the technique for white to try to push
forward you said it very well yourself
white is going to try to push forward
white is going to try to put his King on
F4 he's going to try to drive this King
away from F6 so precisely what you said
so that he can go or meet with his King
forwards at the same time he's also
going to try to nurse his Pawn up the
board why did Black play H5 because when
you do get this position with your King
on F4 you don't want to see G4 G5 and
you're getting crowded away so anytime
white offers a pawn trade like move G4
black is going to take it
and anytime you go F4 F5 black is going
to take it so black is looking for Pawn
trades white is looking to
press and squeeze his way forwards
oftentimes black just leaves this Rook
along the sixth
rank so that you can't play check and
you can't push the king away you rather
you're going to have to play E5 check
which is usually a move that you like to
keep in reserve so the only thing that
you could try to get in this position
though it's extremely extremely
difficult is a position in which you
have the E and F pawns as white on the
board remaining against the g-pawn you
unfortunately that's almost impossible
to get in this certain situation and
look what uh
Wesley has done he's gone Rook to H1 to
provoke the move G3 why is that
important well you can simply sit with
your Rook on G1 and say to your opponent
well now your king is forever Tethered
to the G3 Square yes you can check me
apartment let me just put the Rook on G1
yes you can check me and force me back
and he's done precisely that but then
anytime your king tries to move I'm
gonna
cash the pawn you know with Rook takes
so what Wesley is saying for you to make
progress you're going to have to play G3
G4 I'll trade I'll trade I I really like
your king of seven move by the way you
did yep I I don't think you should be
playing King to G7 because why I felt
that it was a concession because you do
have ideas of Rook D7 opening up by E5
and then you're forcing my king to go
backwards some more okay
yeah but I but Rook G1 I also like the
uh lines where you you you keep your
king upon me you keep your Rook on the
side and you check the white king
whenever you get an opportunity to do so
by the way E5 check on the board asking
Wesley right here right now to Define
where you're going to put your king I
think he's gonna tuck it in on G7 you
think oh I think so so check that out
coach over there saying King G7 might be
a better I'm not saying it's better I'm
just saying it's I think he's gonna want
to tuck it in
one simple fact for example if you go
King G7 and Rook D7 I can defend against
that multiple ways I can go King G8 or
King f8 or I can just simply go rookie
one I like rookie one as well because a
moment ago the pawn on G3 required
protection now after rookie one it's the
pawn on E5 yeah it will require
protection King G7
and we do have King G7 we do have Rook
D7
and I think at this point uh time oops I
think I lost my screen time is not a an
issue anymore right there there are a
few things that black should be very
careful of okay and that is for instance
if white were to go Rook to D6 okay
and say you just make a past move I
don't know rookie too okay E6 E6 is an
idea to be aware of the whole thing is
that after Pawn takes porn Okay you can
step forward I wanted to give Rook D7
check
ing backwards yes so this is what you
have to fear exactly if you get this if
you get this then it's gonna be bad news
then suddenly you know what the problem
is I can pick with the Rook on E6 and I
think that pawn and game is just a very
easy draw right so
this is the one thing that you should be
worried about but if this pawn and game
is is a draw then nothing to worry let
me just I agree but in this circumstance
it's a draw so often what's going to
happen is these crafty end game grind
Masters as we call them they they trick
you they move their pieces they move the
Rook doing nothing moves and before you
know it
and you suddenly put yourself your king
somewhere ridiculous
right
um I find it intriguing that uh Hikaru
just now played the move Rook A5 he did
have an opportunity of playing rookie
three and then playing what you wanted
to play was E6 uh Hikaru did not do that
and Rook A5 rookie two on the board of
course E6 will get three versus two and
once again we do know that's a pretty
straightforward draw rookie one uh
pardon me Rook A6 inviting Rook E1
and he goes for it it's exactly
when they need to wait they know how to
wait
they know how to not do anything and
create any weakness
by the way in that classical game
where Wesley sacrificed his Queen
and suddenly ended the game in stalemate
that was like a snap finish right I
don't think we caught the queen we
didn't catch it at all and it was on the
plate it was so to speak for I don't
know five moves right it never even
occurred towards once exactly and he and
when he put that down I was like you
know my snap you know that was great uh
Rook E1 we don't think time that the the
difference in the clocks make any
difference however I do think it's 23
minutes for 23 minutes Hikaru started
with 25 let's remind everybody here we
go and he finally has played rookie four
so he is I'm anticipating this is going
to drive the Rook to G to the G file so
that you don't have King G5 G file or
the E file or da files sorry okay he's
played it to the to the side
anticipating E6 and he'll get a checks
on the side one thing you don't want to
do that's why please is go King G5 Rook
A5 and now F4
that would be awkward and that would be
a big a bit awkward yes yeah actually
that looks like a pretty good puzzle
Rush tactic right there you know just to
be observant that you would walk into a
Checkmate that was I don't know coach
that's a bad sign when you're seeing
everything that can go wrong you know
paranoia yeah yeah yeah right
let me just refresh my board it'll just
like a quick second Hikaru trying to
confuse the game
the game by just moving his King
backwards yeah that's not
going to get anywhere
it's just uh trying to create some now
is your chance to go E6 if you really
want to well
in a moment you may not get the chance
again right because if I put my king
there the moment you play rookie three
that is a drawn reckon a king bonding
game very very quickly so after the move
King f8 it's almost one of those Now or
Never situations and the problem is if
you go E6 I can give you a check
oh
we're going to get into Jovi's line wait
a minute Jovi's Jovi might might
suddenly
be be happy if I would be very happy but
I don't think it's okay that matters too
much
commentators happiness is not a part of
the tournament complex uh there
um yeah no it's still what can I say
it's still pretty clearly drawn
after this Rook A3 and Wesley in fact
decided to take pause go check on the
Blitz Games see what's happening in
those
he's not at work right now he's not at
the board no no
is
he's not allowed
to uh
other than stay in the playing oh wow
absolutely oh absolutely Rook E3 and
hikar is very happy that his opponent's
clock is taking how much time does
Wesley have well he's got loads of time
in the world so he's got uh just over 12
and a half minutes Hikaru Nakamura has
23 minutes I think Hikaru wants to
finish the game with more time on his
clock than what he started
I mean there's something to talk about
on stream
but other than that I don't see him
making any breakthroughs here uh and
clickbait headline there yeah right I
gained more how to draw with more time
than when you started exactly
I'd click on such a stream yeah
yeah uh here I would probably use black
Shaq throwing a check yeah and just see
just test what are you going to do are
you going to put your King on G1 he
might be ready to take a draw he might
just be ready to go rookie to rookie 3.
rookie Rook a two rookie 2 and back and
forth he might be ready to do that yes
no no okay five
didn't guess that one
once again if I don't play oh he's
played F4
I was about to say if he if I don't play
E6
uh I may never play six but now the
question is is it ridiculous to get
ambitious I think so yes because I go on
the B file or or the C file for them
okay so I go King E7 tell me why
tell me why this is not ambitious B3
Rook B3 and I'll go
okay you have to be careful because
you're setting up this position that
I've seen so King goes to F3 and now now
you don't know you must play King E6
because if you don't do that if I don't
do that yeah
then I can go F5
ah yes yes that's dangerous now I'm
gonna start laughing weaknesses okay so
Rook sorry I'm gonna refresh my board it
takes just a quick second so now he's
brought his Rook back down so presumably
whenever you go F5 and King F3 is going
to check you
uh on the first rank
and the Hikaru delivers a check
King E6 can step backwards can step
forwards I definitely would like to be
different I I you know it's funny I
don't want if you ask me I wouldn't want
to allow
that's a good that's a great point so uh
if you can balance
so I would like to place my king
actually on the E6 Square be a little
bit more active force you to check me
and
you know this position and now if you
like you're right now you can go if you
want for the F5 he's reaching for that
is he really yes
reaching for the F Bond and maybe
playing for Rook F6 I don't know
and he's done it coach
F5 only chess right right only chest so
again where this is the current position
we're anticipating captures although
Rook is there something to be said for
Rook A4 A5 can I start giving you checks
okay I have one question can I start
giving you checks
yeah
um the board check I'll be moving up the
board thank you
check on G4 when you go to G5 yes this
feels much more now I take on F5 like
like a draw than it does a win suddenly
because I do have
uh although I'm gonna
okay I go King E6 yeah
once you take on the H5 I go F6 I'm
happy exactly that indeed let's show
that to the audience uh coach tells me
F6 and that just shuts down any
Ambitions that I have okay so you like
check immediately and not to capture the
pawn
yes he played Rook 83 actually
just drive the king down the board I
guess the only way to try to hide it is
via H3 but okay let's imagine we do get
to H3
and now I can defend it so I then I take
what do you do now and Rook F6 you know
you don't have to and now as soon as you
go after this guy F4 yes for trades them
off yeah he's going for it he he found
definitely Wesley knows that defensive
technique
he found the setup
I don't think Hikaru is uh is going to
try for much longer right now
not that you're taking any risks even if
King G5 you play King G5 you allow me or
G4 you're not taking anything no no of
course why
it's how practical is it to kind of draw
out this game for as long as possible
well we just saw King G5 okay King five
players are moving down the line very
very quickly indeed and everything is
calculated at this point we're going to
see Rook F6 maybe Rook takes G3 and can
you start by taking the pawn on H5 will
that make any difference
he's gone for it
yeah
what happens if white plays Rook G5 I
will take that that's what I was gonna
do too
whoa why not
because I'm always reluctant to go into
Kingdom
I know I know it can be dangerous but
just to make sure I take
you know King F5 this is uh easy draw
yes
um king of five I would I would go for
you would have preferred King F5 king of
five King H6 King G4 immediately
attacked the pawn that's that's okay H5
King H4 and that Force you get this yeah
it is a draw with many many moves
including F6
sorry in this position no not yeah and
the one before King E6 so in the current
position including the move F7 F6 is
also a drop and this would be like
blundering upon or two and even that's a
draw wow okay
it sounds like a draw and it is a draw
uh
even without varusian in the studio just
to give you an update on the blister man
version actually Drew Lanier in the
second round so it's dark he's doing
well good start well I mean uh our VAR
has to uphold the honors of the
production team you know I mean he's in
studio
each day he's he's telling he's telling
uh the production what's going on you
know and you know he's got to earn that
the respect
pesky commentators yes podcasters right
the lowest to the low
that's awesome right and I think
podcasters are just
we're just half A Step Above
commentators are half A Step Above
podcast why because we're more
challenged
we work longer hours
what has he played he's found another
way of forcing a draw has Hikaru and
he's gone for
well I don't even know what he what
would you would call this this is hardly
a winning attempt Rook G8 I think it's
the easiest Rook G8 you take my
why wouldn't we play King of six well
you can actually look at this because I
want to force it and remove drawers
and let me tell you the losing moves the
losing moves are Rook A3 you're not
going to play that yeah and Brooke G6
there anything else
so you have three moves that drop a
whole rook and everything else draws
exactly just don't don't blunder your
Rook Rook G8 threaten rook h8 and that's
it
yep
he goes for it we're probably going to
see King H6 Okay Jade little cage seven
no
no the car says Rook H7 first
there was a movie made on the racehorse
Secretariat
and Secretariat wins the Belmont Stakes
by like 30 lengths and the trainer John
Malkovich shouts out to the guy on the
horse don't fall off
his face
either don't blunder your Rook Wesley
how could you not play King G7
that's funny whoa whoa whoa I'm just
making sure well one stalemate uh
brought about another stalemate that was
that was intriguing to say the least as
the first game is a draw it is a draw
and I do feel that Hikaru playing with
the white pieces will perhaps be
disappointed with that outing because
you do want to put your opponent under a
little bit more pressure than hikara did
yeah the opening novelty well it was
kind of a bust I mean nothing happened
the players played all Theory got into
an isolated Queen Pond position and
right here Hikaru played the move Bishop
F3 all the pieces came off and it was a
very very comfortable draw very
comfortable they're also they're going
to do it all again colors reversed and
the winner of the next game wins the
whole thing yeah unless unless and then
we're gonna go to playoffs and uh a lot
faster time control but in the meanwhile
do we uh pop in there we go let's let's
take a look at what's happening in the
blitz event and we are looking at the
game between Sam Shanklin and Aram
hakobian who actually defeated
levonaronian with the black pieces in
the second round this is round three
round three of nine okay thirty thousand
dollars surprise money that's a pretty
significant price one tournament yeah to
a minute 30.
uh I like Sam Sam's chances as well
the faith push the pawn oh he could have
played Rook check and taken the pawn on
B3 ooh now that's a No-No you got to
make sure that all the pieces are
properly on their squares by the time
you press your clock oops check now you
can just take it let's exchange that
yeah
and push okay
oh no the problem is you can promote
your pawns
okay you just crawl up the board Sam
Jacqueline has won nice win uh by the
ways Fabiano caruano versus Benjamin
Bach on board one is still ongoing right
now right I don't know if we have camera
feed for that one okay you see the
Letterman's jackets
all right here we go there we go
Benjamin Bach is back towards is one of
Holland's uh Olympic team players
top
Grandmaster and I think he goes to
Webster no he goes to St Louis
University I apologize he goes to salute
yes my bad
and Bobby that's a nice past a pawn I'm
looking there's a couple of nice past
pawns deepon and the Apon two pawns up
but you have to be worried about the
check that's coming up that was about
Benjamin it's it's set up A7 that's
supported by the queen queen to ca
trying to avoid promotion
A1 oh that's a nasty move that forces
the queen trade which is the one thing
Benjamin didn't want Rook to B1 or to V8
yeah
and that's all she wrote
B7 first
D5 followed by D6
party hand clasp
does that mean that Fabby goes 2-0 at
3-030 Bobby's On 3-0 right now wow
I just wanted to say that uh thirty
thousand dollars in prizes is brought
out the best in the universities the
locals all coming it's a who's who of
American chess playing in this
competition and a big shout out to St
Louis chess club for sponsoring this
event and the results yes the result it
was a very hard Port draw between Hikaru
Nakamura with the white pieces against
Wesley so
does mean that whoever wins the next
rapid game will be the winner of the
2023 American Cup and 30 minutes from
now they will play again yeah the goal
will start game two and as you say it
will be sudden death winner wins
but in the meanwhile uh let's check in
on our friends at Cuba too we've got a
five percent of this yes
so much because I love it when you do
the modeling you do it so well and look
I'm the eye candy on the show I I accept
the role what can I say
what is the special okay as a thank you
for watching the 2023 American Cup
please enjoy 20 of 20 regular price
merchandise today only with a cup and
cup 20 at checkout offer valid only at Q
Boutique stl.com so 20 off everything
sweet that is amazing
wow wow do exploit the moment uh the
American Cup 2023 our last day and as we
get uh ready for break we're gonna be
saying our thank yous to so many people
behind the scene we'll see you on the
other side of a break
[Music]
foreign
Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
it's 2023 and the grand chest tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grandchester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best joint
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
sagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
foreign
thank you
are back and it's Championship Sunday at
the American Cup whilst we're waiting
for the Grand Final of Hikaru Nakamura
versus Wesley so to resume well we're
going to take a look at the American Cup
Blitz it's round four and we see Sam
Shanklin getting ready with the white
pieces against Fabiana caruana and what
I noticed about Sam is he's wearing his
us Championship shirt the one he won
that's what I was gonna say
that's got to be a lucky shirt good year
2018 an excellent vintage is these two
Olympic teammates Get Ready To Duel
and off they go
Christian who do you like in the in the
battle go with a nimzo
um
I mean it's very difficult to bet
against uh Fabi especially in recent
years if it was a few years back when he
was supposedly not that good in Blitz
maybe I would have bet on Sam but I have
to say Fabiano has perfected his uh
rapid and Blitz play quite a lot in the
last few years this last move E3 does it
invite Knight to D5 and Knight B6 it
certainly does he didn't do it he just
says go ahead win back the pawn on C4
nobody's stopping you Bishop takes C4
and I think Knight D5 maybe Knight to E5
is something that black was worried
about
okay
and I'm sure this is still Theory oh
gosh yes this players still no other day
and uh Fabby dropping the bishop back so
that he can prepare an E5 yes Bingo yeah
that's what it's all about the bishop on
C8 needs a a direct route into the game
and E6 E5 will provide that oftentimes
black also throws in the move a7a6 so
there's no tickles with Knight B5 the
bishop on D6 enjoys the role it's
playing in the game Rook D1 getting set
up for specifically E5 right and he's
playing up a cannon against that Queen
on d8 but unfortunately you don't have
any Discovery attacks quite yet for the
moment
okay for me this is uh giving black an
easy game this captures in Bishop E2 I
get to play in my in my view you know
moves like Queen E7 and Bishop to G4 and
if you want to take my knight I'll set
up that battery with alacrity well here
we go Bishop G4 he's inviting Bishop G4
and I think for my taste uh Black's got
an early initiative here maybe it's not
nothing to be proud of that much but
Knight takes F3 doubling up those pawns
that's a severe threat oh yes and right
now Sam shacklin dropping down to these
last two minutes against two means and
36. so Fabiano is building up a nice
time Advantage as well right and can Sam
just bail out with something
Knight takes E5 Queen takes E5 F4 no
he's gone for this wow I like this for
Sam I like this idea for salmon try to
do something very concrete yes that's a
strange sortie that night on F3 I
thought was doing a good job defending
the king I'm not sure what it's doing it
got bounced to B5 but it provoked C5 is
that a bad thing well yes and no because
yes because you're gaining some time for
black okay but no because you're living
behind some squares D5 as well as B5
those are very weak squares in the
position H3 now again I'm I'm super
happy here's black I'm playing Bishop D7
yes keeping the threats of Bishop
sacrifices if Bishop takes H3 alive then
I come back with my queen but I'm also
looking eyeballing A6 and sending that
Knight on B5 into purgatory on A3 where
do you whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
now that can't be right 86 no no no
that's that's too much that that has to
be 12. whoa A6 might have just won the
game there you take on E5 Queen takes E5
I'm hitting H2 I'm winning back the
Knight on B5 by the way well the ninth
is going back to A3 anyway
no this is going wrong for Samsung
but I I really think that that move
Knight G6 was not needed that he missed
a winning a winning moment there and the
problem is you don't have Bishop to C3
setting up that Bishop on the wrong
diagonal because of B4 so the Knight is
offsides on A3 clear you're not doing
anything there but the bishop cannot go
back to see it cannot go to C3 probably
will have to be rerouted via E1 is not
looking comfortable for white yeah I
think the white knight but it can okay
you can just admit that it's gonna on a
erroneous journey and just go back to B1
and go hey look at that okay by the way
I thought thought this move C4 was
setting up for Queen C5 and maybe some
awkward things so this move E3 E4
defends the bishop and well Queen C5
check maybe still is good Queen C5 check
in 97 uh he wants to play Bishop C5
check makes sense makes a lot of sense
but you're right that night on A3 is
just an eyesore for me he's got to bring
that Knight to B1 to C3 and back into uh
civilization
it should be three Rook C7 not even
Bishop C5 not going for the bishop trade
right how convinced whether is the right
thing somehow Sam is right right at the
ship a little bit here you think so I
think so the night once the night gets
to C3 I don't see why he's not a happy
camper you he will have ideas of e for
E5 himself once you put the Knight on C3
I want to go B4 as fast as possible okay
and what happens if you just like
get crafty with the queen and put her on
H4 hmm that's aggressive yeah
uh B4 not even waiting for the Knight to
show up but just stopping but also
inviting Knight D2 92 C3 he needs to do
something but 92 C3 Knight C4 the Knight
kind of looked oh you might have Bishop
B5 okay yeah yeah you've got Bishop B5
ID 92 C3 C3 right right you can start
with Bishop B5 if you want but I think
C3 makes the most sense there should be
five at a certain moment maybe I just
take this pawn and just challenge you to
prove and Sam now on maybe right now and
right here right now down to 20 seconds
and what's going to happen is that's two
okay that side steps C3 sorry I know I
was gonna say just wait for it because
Sam now is feeling the pressure he's
feeling the heat yes he is and he will
play great and then he will just crack
not just him but I mean in general in
general this happens you know you can
play 20 good moves and then at some
point when you have seconds remaining it
happens it all falls apart if you lose
your mind that's when you make the
mistakes yeah Knight F1 and it does feel
like
like Fabby is using his majority to
effect and at the moment the pawns on e4
and four are just simply stuck question
is what do you do with the Knight on G6
or do you just sit with it well he's
taken for the moment and maybe not G3
it's just sitting Knight takes F4 was a
threat so he sidestepped that with King
tuition right unpinning The Rook which
now defends the pawn on at least that
one right G3 Knight is perhaps coming
into F5
and uh so far there's a three-way tie
for first place between Sam Seville
Fabiana caruana and Sam Shanklin and
Bishop takes F7 does not work because1
D7 is in fact protected by the bishop on
B5 you don't see it very clearly no that
Bishop
but it does it does feel like an uh an
awesome extra Pawn for uh Fabi at the
moment because on Rook D3 yeah uh
something maybe to be said for Bishop to
to D3 to G6 I want to root D3 just yeah
Bishop D3 Queen C1 and Bishop G6 just
making sure that oh he's thinking
that was not necessary Bishop to G6 well
it threatens Rook G5 and I do like that
uh idea very much
that would be very bad yes
and this move sets up rook h
Rook H5 Rook G5 Rook H5 would have also
just kicked the queen Rook C5 trying to
promote that c Pawn I I think the
players have both missed Rook H5 whoa
Rook F3 Rook takes C4 B takes C4 can we
promote no the queen on H6 is defending
Queen f8 just get out of there and there
you go rooked
uh
bravo bravo that broke somebody started
it at four four zero and that's somebody
and it seems like uh Fabiano operin
versus Savion it's going savion's way
okay and Savion might be moving on to
three out of three as well four out of
four out of four and two players on
second
yep he's got this he's gonna go to see
if it's
a mate and uh I've seen enough
Bravo Sam as Sam keeps the pace a four
out of four and in this field by the way
scoring four out of four is crazy good
lenia Dominguez Sam shankland I mean Ray
Robson Sam sevillion Gregory
Benjamin Bach darush swertz who made it
to New York Championship program Masters
in a 37 player field wow and and a lot
of ladies too the ladies uh all from the
American Cup uh joining the action as
well
and just to remind everybody where we
stand in the grand finals
game between Aaron Nakamura and
of Wesley's comeback match win yesterday
it means that the players are on equal
footing whoever wins this match is going
to take home the title of American Cup
winner I'm with you all the way though
I'm looking forward to an armaged
Armageddon and a blitz throughout to
keep us entertained but we're going to
take a short break and come back for the
second game of the playoffs
foreign the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr Jeannie
Karen singfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a non-profit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Championship Sunday it's
the final day of the American Cup and in
the big playoffs between Hikaru Nakamura
and Wesley so we are still waiting for
game two to begin and in the meantime we
are going to go and uh take a look at
the American Cup Blitz event around five
and we are going to look at what games I
believe it was as this game between uh
Alejandro and I'm going to say that is
Robbie cavalish Villi versus Levon
aronia the Georgian cash Billy I'm gonna
get that wrong uh Lavon
will be black
and are they wait a minute I thought it
was San Savion and uh probably who were
for oh
wow but uh okay this is going to be a
marquee matchup and what
what are we expecting uh do do you know
something about uh Bobby oh I I know
Robbie very well he's uh an opponent at
St Louis University of our University at
the University of Missouri and he's a
very good Blitz player that's actually
one of his specialty okay when it comes
to short time controls I think he's just
a com rating is close to 3 000. so wow
he's he's good he's definitely good and
uh yeah he's no pushover even against
lebronia age four I I like the fact that
Lavon you know is playing the neither of
Sicilian against
a non-wesley non-hikaru opponent no
berlins for you we want to play really
really sharp but the inclusion of H4
Jovi I know and now I have four I mean I
like that the disrespect
uh Queen to C7 just to sidestep F4 F5 it
looks strange to see both H4 as well as
f4 on the board and for Lavon as well
Lavon says when you play H4 and F4 you
can't defend the G4 Square I can secure
that square for my knight with the move
H5 which he's done keep in mind Robbie
is also a neither player himself
so he's showing something that he might
be afraid of in his own thing exactly he
knows some details for sure okay just
move uh Bishop D7 is set up for Bishop
C6 followed by Knight D7 and there's a
big fight for
d57 yet because
actually yes there might be a 97. I was
going to ask a Christian and perhaps you
yourself might know as well
do the students at the St Louis
universities
help you know some of the world's
strongest players like we have Lavon
living here Fabiano
I mean is there a nice kind of synergy
of talent I I would say absolutely
absolutely yes because of course as we
all know universally around the globe
students are starving end of story so if
you've got these starving students who
are really really talented down the
street you go to them and say hi dude
the come and work for me for a couple of
hours each and every week I'll make sure
give you some pizza money and keep me in
that's a bit harsh yeah
I'm starving absolutely come on
what else do you learn about University
life I mean you learn where where you
can go and have uh the buffets you do
that when you have like student loans
and you pay yourself for University most
of these Grand Masters they come here
they get full rights that's true they
get full rides at the best universities
here in Missouri they get to play Chess
at the top level and indeed they do get
to train with the best chess players as
well well it was Wesley I think that he
mentioned during one of the interviews
that he saw Fabiano hanging around with
Gregory apartment and he was afraid of
his Catalan and that's why he shied away
from Catalan with the qga so there's
definitely some uh Synergy as you
mentioned yes sir
Bishop E7 on the board and again I'm
just
if I'm black in these Knight art
positions
I'm not a I'm not
absolutely eager I'm not absolutely
eager to Castle and declare my
intentions uh but kind of keeping my
king in the center that seems pretty
decent
Rook C8 by Lavon
at a certain moment aren't you playing
for B4 B5 B4 and a6a5
a Christian yeah that seems like a good
plan big moment right now for Robbie how
do you meet this potential expansion on
the queen side
Knight to D5 okay to D5 changing
changing the character of the position
and the structure
I'm surprised by that move I must say uh
it
seems to clarify everything that's
suddenly gone on and it is but how do
you continue right now as black you
don't have A5 because
B5 is hanging but okay I would be shying
away from that because after E4 I get to
hop with my knight via D4 either to C6
or even E6
yeah I must say I
I wasn't sure about this queen B6 either
maybe something like Queen C7 but okay
uh in any case Bishop to D3 inviting
uh E4 and Knight E5
whoa uh
I guess E4 Bishop E4 no just Knight G4
oh and here we've seen fighting that
trade on E7 maybe a benefit of keeping
the king in the center but I like it I
like it I feel like strategically right
now Levon is making the right decisions
he's exchanging the good pieces for him
and taking full advantage of the fact
that you have some weaknesses left by
this thing that you mentioned long long
time ago this idea and connection of H4
followed by F4 right you see that square
G4 weak interesting move from uh Robbie
he just moved his Rook
to E1
and the queen comes down thread of
Queens I like this idea by Levon
once your king is in danger and sorry to
break away we we're just going to take a
look at the opening moves between uh
Wesley and Karo but we're not going to
leave you hanging on the result of that
Blitz game that we were just watching
all right Knight F6 uh Berlin
No Kalashnikov Cassie today are we
inviting no we're not inviting
the Berlin end game uh oh now these two
players know each other so well
from this whole Berlin complex it I
would be amazed if Wesley were able to
get any opening Edge because the players
are just so conversant yeah and uh
Hikaru just re-routing the night and
okay we're gonna leave the players in
this opening stages and we're going to
head back to
fighting Blitz game we left it with
Queen F2 on the board yeah we left it
with black offering a queen trade
obviously white said nope not gonna go
for that one and look at this great move
by now the queen trade is absolutely
obliged Queen takes F takes and now
Knight is gonna come to the E5 Square
which is a dream square is going in
these night orbs and take a look at that
H Pawn running down the board as well
okay white has his own ideas Knight to
C6 on a good day rookie Rook H1 and the
pawn gets all the way to Age Two where
it's finally been blocked oh but now if
you oh I could go
Knight E3 what about 19 F1 oh nice nice
one Knight F4 and Knight G3 isn't that
winning something
so you start with night no
okay but I think he still keeps the idea
of my F1 in his pocket I agree 10
seconds it keeps the whole
oh he's going for Something Completely
there's a mate on C1 don't play no no
mate yeah no no it's only three
and uh we lost the camera almost
if you think of Santa he thinks it's
tense on the board wait till you see our
cameraman
he's taking the most strategical
approach he just wants to play with the
pawn up by the way is there a hazard pay
for the cameraman you you come between
the players when they're blitzing the GT
Pawn is hanging and it looks like like
LaVon all the way get the king in seven
seconds to 20 seconds and lavon's got
dominant position he's looking good
within extra Pawn pounds on the D4 Pawn
yes sir it's another Pawn dropping right
now there's nothing you can do about in
Knight to C4 Rook to E2 and rookie oh
that's a nasty move anytime you can
transpose I mean the tricks are still B2
B2 is hanging take take yes but that's a
munch
night June coming back to C4 as well
before
Knight can come back to see for give me
the A3 Pawn
that's another Munch yes sir Lavon is
just stripping white of all of his pawns
came to E4 perhaps
I love it run that bee Pawn push him
baby
Shaq
E3 he wants to take on F4 with the
Knight and go Knight to D3 stop the pawn
the promise Knight C4 is coming and so
is A5 A4 A3 this force is resignation
and there you have it well very nicely
played game by Lavon let's jump back to
our finals and we have this rookie too
from uh the world championship match
before that can we hop to the Fabiano
versus Savion game the last moments of
that one
the two players with four out of four
yeah but who wants to watch the winners
play against one of them
uh I'm not sure we're set up for that
whoa whoa Rico I was wrong
users yeah sir come on never doubt never
doubt the production team
or is that a bishop on C6
well now he has to move the Rook can I
go Knight
well
it suddenly become a became a little bit
tricky unless you have a knight H3 to G5
ah well that is a tricky move you're
threatening Knight C3 check
and Knight C3 check will pick up the
pump
sad enough and that's
two perfect leaders for the moment
well somebody's going to be imperfect I
can tell you that four out of the four
for the moment and it does seem like
Fabiano is probably going to keep the
streak going
that's a Chuck be careful very nice
check just forces you to declare and
leaves the night
ready to uh
that's another channel oh at some point
I will have to check on e4 perhaps yeah
by the King five
no winning again
feel the force I do I do yes I'm trying
my best there you go uh jumping back to
uh now
I'm thinking from the graphic that you
showed us earlier if I'm in Wesley's
shoes I really want to avoid the three
versus two three and two I want to avoid
that those pair of games I'm trying to
get something out of these two games uh
does Wesley have anything with the white
pieces according to the engine's uh
Christian no it's even even Stephen Even
Stevens even if I get in a move like C4
and Bishop C3 and D5 and by even I mean
a 0.2 Advantage okay so I would
recommend that as Eva so I I'm thinking
that I can at least stifle the bishop
it's a nice word stuff yellow thank you
working on my
on the knowledge C4 all right let's try
to exchange everything
yeah Bishop to C3 I see what you're
trying to do right now wow that's all
for it I I kind of uh waving a red flag
over here okay can I exchange
trade trade I don't actually have to do
it yet but let's try it trade trade
and now you want to I'll continue
trading Queen E6 yeah you can you can oh
sorry you can force another oh no you
can't sorry background issues we need
through her Queen E6 sure and this is
where we by just trading everything
I've got a wedgie but it's nothing uh
maybe even B5 right now even he has a B5
you go B3 perhaps wait a minute wait a
minute
aren't you making uh I take on D5 yeah
but aren't you making a imbalance that
could potentially might cost me I I
agree
but yeah if you were going to play
something I like yeah I like you
breaking up the team enough to C6 you
can just take it and there's really
nothing exactly and by the way
this position has been reached before
between shirov and kramnik in 2016. this
is we're still in the throes of fairies
wow yes what yes yes how did that game
end between kramnik and Sheriff oh just
a second let me exercise my I'm gonna
I'm gonna say draw
no and you would be right
right barely again uh the first game was
a draw this is the second game if this
one is a draw they'll continue the
playoffs but the games will accelerate
or rather the tempo of the games will
accelerate Rook E6
okay so this was 2016 kramnik versus
Sheriff wow
yeah two great names from the past I
always feel
with Wesley and Hikaru don't they play
very slow games to begin with and then
somewhere at the midpoint the match is
always heat up that's right they get
better and better and
it's like somehow there's like a mutual
agreement between the two that they're
not going to bring the heavy weapons
until game three or something right this
is my theory okay what do you call the
heavy weapons
involve some sort of a systemic risk
right so whenever you play that you know
that you're most likely going to be
worse or at least allowing your opponent
if they play Perfect moves to be worse
but as the time gets shorter and shorter
those perfect moves are more and more
difficult to find right so this is what
I think the strategy is for both of
these players specifically for Hikaru in
my opinion in this particular matches
because we've seen him as a the
Kalashnikov whenever we get down to the
blitz so I think we're going to see
something similar in this reiteration of
their encounter
a question yeah these two players to
mine to my mind very very different
approaches to to chess different styles
uh and yet they're so close
uh to one another rating wise score wise
how do you account for the fact that
they can play such a different brand of
Chess and yet be so close to one another
I think the differences have evened out
over the years they're not as
significant nowadays all of these top
players are very Universal in their
approach they can play
very different types of positions very
well at the a little level
defensive nowadays you have strategic as
as 27 80 close to 2800 level player you
have to be able to play every single
position given and make the best out of
your circumstances
and how would you categorize Wesley so
style as opposed to Hikaru Nakamura I
always thought of Wes pardon me Wesley
as a very objective player very
pragmatic player he's not trying to
force the action but his positional
judgment is simply outstanding he just
you don't see him getting positionally
outplayed but he's doing it all the time
to his opposition
now maybe his tactical
ability you know is not up to the
standards to say of the schwannathon and
Anon but you know on these positional
levels
is he's just he's got it all by the way
they are following
our analysis but are they still
following the kramnik game that would be
remarkable absolutely not uh the kramnik
game actually continued with uh White
playing c2c3 just solidifying the
structure much more solid yeah
and C4 a little bit more ambitious again
this was the space gaming ideas that I
had seen uh Christian just traded the
Rooks a moment ago against me and then
traded the Queens
with Queen E6 as well and I got an end
game
all we thought was minutely better if
that there is something
right no draw offers at all in any of
the American Cup games regardless of the
time controls whether it be classical or
Armageddon right exactly know your
office allowed is what I meant to say
and
this means that the players will have to
play even in the most tepid of positions
I I and there was a couple of those
games where one player was leading one
zero and wanted to draw from a winning
position would have offered a draw just
to clinch the match wasn't allowed to do
so and they had to win 2-0 to uh to move
on and so one of the most annoying
things about the no draw offers yes
rated player is playing someone super
high rated maybe a super Grand Master
and somehow or either you find yourself
in a winning position happened to one of
my friends he was playing vision and
found himself three pawns up
sounds like a lot but then it became two
pawns up and then he could feel that the
flow was was going was not going his way
and so he really wanted to offer a
drawer
yeah it wasn't allowed because it was
Corsican rules at the time I hate it and
then it became two ports became one pawn
and he was like
ended up losing
three pawns up that hurts that hurts
Bishop C3 uh Christian any I mean any
tactics here that the players have to no
uh
I really like this idea going to F4
Force G3 and now Queen F3 exactly
exactly well that's what he's done yes
and he wants a forces to trade on his
terms uh that is to say if you want to
trade Rooks let me let me uh capture
towards the center the meanwhile Queen
F3 visual takes F3 you were just one
massive simplification yeah a one ply
away from playing D5 and you know
perhaps uh getting some kind of a clamp
on the position Rook takes easy to see
massive implications right now you mean
takes and Bishops takes C6 perhaps take
they take Bishop G2
Force another trade and then move on to
the next stage and plus five again I
always talk about that of uh trade on
your own terms like in this particular
position I don't know if you would want
to trade maybe find it all right I might
want to play the move Rook E3 with the
idea of giving this bishop which I think
of as a powerful Bishop a boot you know
with uh with Rook E3 we'll see if the
players agree with that I I agree with
you I also have to say it depends on how
ambitious you are because I feel like
rookie 3 is a winning attempt for white
if you just wanted to clinically finish
the game as quickly as possible maybe
you can even go Bishop G2 and say let's
trade off everything exactly so here the
question that uh uh Hikaru is wrestling
with should he keep a pair of Rooks on
the board with the move F7 takes E6 a
move that I personally find very
attractive I like I like controlling the
center more I like introducing the pawn
and anything like Bishop G2 I could
potentially meet with real Cafe right
and just say again I don't mind you
trading I just want you to do it on my
terms
something of this nature well we'll see
what happens now because he has played
by the way F7 takes E6 and that could be
a very natural follow-up in this
position
take on F3 take on F3 and now
do you want to allow the route to go to
D3 maybe not and get active like that
then you can offer the root trade with
root two by the way this is a dragon
confirmation but it's actually on the
queen side
reverse Dragon yeah like yeah you flip
this flip the mirror kind of dragon
sorry I can just say I like your
observations
um I could just see
um a forced a repetition how Okay so
Bishop T2 it's in your line that you
mentioned
yep Bishop takes Bishop yep
you could play King E2 potentially too
if you want to keep the game alike but
that's one repetition by the way these
guys sniff those repetitions out really
well they know they're good they they
they they know their tricks
so F takes E6 on the board is time are
the clocks effect no not really yes
Hikaru Nakamura with the black pieces
22 minutes Wesley so just under 18
minutes loads of time comfy
and we do have two tournaments going on
and guess what uh big match is happening
right now on board one in that one Levon
aronian versus Fabiano coron we've we've
seen these two guys battle each other
for the last couple of weeks so many
times this American Cup that's seven
that that playoff 7 out of seven
decisions seven out of seven decisive
games uh that will go down in the annals
of history as one of the greatest
matches I've ever seen and it was LaVon
in the end who knocked the the defending
Champion out of the elimination bracket
yes four to three yes Armageddon that
was the first and only only Armageddon
right
by the way it's been such a long while
that I've ever seen
a stalemate
right like think about it you've seen
King versus King pretty often but
stalemates are even much rarer than that
and then in this match we've seen two
stalemates actually here uh D5
now that was a move we didn't look at we
were looking at Bishop G2 but D5 says
I'm going to try to create a weakness if
you allow me and for the moment I'm
exploiting
the pen on The Rook good move good move
yes good move
uh that may not have been what
Hikaru angled for when he played the
move F7 takes E6 because if you now play
E5 now Bishop G2
Rook f8 is going to cost you a pawn so
E6 E5 is not something you want I'm
assuming you want to play King F7
if anything I I don't want to be saddled
with an isolated Pawn isn't the problem
with King F7 in fact what you just said
saddle with an isolated Pawn correct
oops I can't say anything on E6 take
with a rook take I mean that's going to
be a dry as well but you don't want to
see the isolated part this is what we
were just talking Jovi yeah yeah yeah I
understand I understood that I was just
looking at ways to avoid this because I
know it's not a big deal but it makes me
slightly uncomfortable and I was going
to ask this question what happens if you
Retreat the bishop and I was just
working out you know you can get H3 I
like it
yeah and then the bishop goes C2 or G6
yeah that's presume G6 and this is what
Wesley is saying that maybe I have
nothing really great to claim but on the
other hand
I have somewhat damaged your Pawn
structure
right and the bishop on C3 is an amazing
amazing so true
um but it's not probably it's still
going to be a draw but uh I am the moral
Victor and do you have to remind
everyone at home especially those people
who just joined us yes that's Wesley so
and Hikaru have actually played one game
prior and they've they've drawn that
much so whoever wins this game will be
the American Cup winner and if it's a if
it's a draw then we're gonna move on to
a rapid playoffs of game ten plus five
or ten plus five gotcha and uh two games
a pair of pair of games that each player
will get black and white for the next
playoff and they'll do that again
if they were tired then we're going to
move on to Blitz playoffs the players
play two games and
only if this is the a draw then it's a
tie then we're going to see the decider
the ultimate decider Armageddon where
white will have white five minutes black
will have four minutes the blackettes
draw odds remarkably enough uh these two
players in this event have played two
playoffs against one another it was
Hikaru emerged victorious in the blitz
playoffs of three plus two but it was
Wesley who emerged victorious in the
Rapids yesterday yeah yesterday's Rapids
of uh ten plus five
so uh
as uh as the match gets closer and
closer or faster and faster I think it
it it it uh is evangelical by the way a
big shout out to varusian right he's
he's having a a nice event he's
currently in eighth position he started
the the tournament the blitz tournament
I'm referring to it the chase down the
road uh in 14th Place he's an eighth
he's hanging around with the big boys
the big boys but he just lost to his
student no that's the worst at the St
Louis University that's the worst
feeling losing to a student look you
should never be your coach but what can
you do actually I think it's this is the
other way around
supposed to be happy that the student uh
has has taken their full measure uh D5
Bishop G4 and there's been a long pause
pause as Wesley has played the move
Bishop to D3 no h3s no G4 Wars but just
improving the bishop temporarily and
maybe getting ready for King G2 to H3
if I'm black I really want to resolve
the tension of this pinned rug so either
I'm playing rookie seven or I'm playing
Rook f8 to resolve this tension and
rookie seven was hikaru's choice and
as a as a grand Masters the more I play
chess the more I learn to despise being
in a pin I just hate being pinned how
about yourself
never Pleasant yeah one of the worst
feelings you can have right I want the
appeal and and all because we have some
nice little Rhymes you know pinning is
winning is winning well that's when
you're on the on the sunny side but you
know
don't despair don't despair there are
always resources in the position and
after rookie seven we do see a trade of
Pawns and Bishop recapture is really
looking like there's nothing in this
position no a slight update on the blitz
ornament Fabiano versus Levon finished
in a draw okay okay the two very very
and by the way were they both at five
zero at the time no no Levon was
definitely not on 5-0 I think he was on
perhaps four out of five but wasn't uh
Fabi yeah yeah Fabi was uh streaking
in a nice way
across the tournament Hall
there's drinking together and analyzing
together as uh as Fabi puts the Kings
properly uh to indicate a draw
ing events you're not a good Streaker
right
I'm sorry really I mean do you have some
experience
well yeah you you need the special Nike
shoes it's all about the shoes
you really want to carry yourself across
the field in a proper way but those
security guys are chasing you down
you got to be fast
experience has taught me
Bishop takes E6 everybody hello uh any
chances for anybody uh Christian it just
sure looks like a balanced game to me
it's a very balanced game I mean
King side I have it on the queen side
this is uh yeah yeah I would say it's
easy but it's not yet that simplified
nevertheless I don't see any future
chances for this top two players
let's take a look at what's happening
next in case that this game does finish
in a draw Joe yeah we are going to go to
an accelerated rapid two-game playoff
where the players are playing with the
time control of 10 minutes plus five
second increment and if the match is
still tied well it gets faster because
they're gonna play a two-game blitz
playoff at the time control three
minutes plus two seconds and if the
match is still tied after all those
games then it eventually is going to be
decided by everyone's favorite or
everyone's most hated an Armageddon game
2023 American Cup is going to go down is
really one of the great fighting
tournaments that has ever been held in
St Louis if this match was to go to an
Armageddon I think it would all go into
kind of a World Chess Hall of Fame
event for Fighting Chess what are the
chances of our Armageddon finals
because it would be fitting because
these two have pushed each other to the
Limit right and you know it's nice to
see them just kind of fight it out in
Echo neck and then Armageddon but I what
I wouldn't want to see is I wouldn't
want to see like
six Bland draws and then an Armageddon
that's not fun I I want to see the
players the first draw the first game
today was as you just described it as
Bland this one also kind of Fairly blank
and it didn't offer us that much in
terms of you know uh exciting exciting
variations but
okay uh is there something to play for
it's a great question is there anything
to play for right now well the space
this activity yeah space for white right
yeah King F3 G4 I mean Joey will tell
you she likes to push her pawns forwards
and she her White's King is a little bit
more prominently placed I mean again
it's nothing
you know that's a decisive tilt in
anybody's favor but I think White's
enjoying the proceedings I tend to agree
yeah I I feel Wesley has gotten a little
bit of something and if you play D5 I
appreciate the fact that you're you have
a passer and I will call it a passer but
it's not a passer that's uh blasting
through and it could easily be blocked I
mean I'm thinking that it might be more
in haikaru's interest to first play H6
bring the king in the center before
playing the move D5 white is not going
to be able to stop D5 right but one of
the downsides of playing H6 yes is that
white
would make I would like to play like H4
H5 G4 set up that pawn formation sure so
let's just do it shall we we'll we'll
put it on the board and now you're
clamping you got the big clan and I'm
gonna try to get the best
exactly exactly uh but like I said only
when my king is in the center and I feel
like you know I can play H5
me D5 under conditions where I can keep
the pawn well protected would I do that
uh maybe maybe what you've just
described is something that Hikaru might
want to stop by playing possibly H5 and
only allowing
h3g4 so H Pawn can be dangerous past F
Pawn less so right right so maybe H5 I
kind of like H5 actually uh and also I
guess something that's running through
both player's mind is sure which Bishop
such a bishops do you want to keep on
the board right
um I was thinking the same thing should
I as white be aspiring to trade light
squared Bishops should I be trying to
trade dark Square Bishops it seems to
mean like all four Bishops are really
good
so I mean you know catches can right
King F3 on the board
um again
taking clocks what's 16 minutes for
Hikaru 13 minutes for West nothing
nothing there on the clocks the clocks
yeah they're not deciding the outcome of
this game but I think this setup H5 King
f8 King E7 makes more sense than H6
because of what you said Joby
yeah he's reaching for his H Pawn
and stopped
G7 G6 okay that's a different setup
G7 G6 there you go F5 now or
uh or do you try to continue you always
are looking at the pawn breaks right and
F4 F5 is
certainly one of the ones that you would
want to look that's on my radar right
right and I would really like to do it
in a way where I would force black to
play Pawn takes Pawn so that your Bishop
would take up those and I have that
outside passport that is always
play the move G 4 and that's fine
nothing's wrong with the move G4
as a strategical player I'm always
motivated by the desire to prove the
scope of my pieces I personally would
have found the move Bishop before very
attractive because I'm thinking if I can
put my Bishop on D6 and blockade your
pawn and you know maybe on a good day
even you know tickle the queen side
I was wondering
get to the pond right but Bishop B4
would have been on my agenda G4 I think
Jovi you you like this uh push him baby
you know I like both plans I didn't even
think about maximizing the bishop but
when you showed it I was like oh yeah
very good because you don't need to rush
with G4 right it's something that you
you're going to do by the way A5
but now you're playing
stopping
this but inviting and whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa inviting Bishop F2
that suddenly is suddenly getting a
little spicy it does doesn't it
wow uh I didn't expect that one uh my
guess is after Bishop to F2 what he
wants is to once again try to simplify
everything on the queen side with B5
okay exchange as many pawns as possible
and even if you lose one of them for
example even if you exchange those A and
B pawns and you lose the d-pawn in the
process that's an easy draw is it yes
that that is for sure an easy draw you
you will be able to create uh some sort
of a blockade on the light squares we've
seen this in the game between in the
Berlin
yeah a very similar situation you will
be able to find the blockade on the
light squares for the King on F7 white
is not going to have much
okay
learn something new every day you watch
a chess program who knew that you could
learn you said the three versus two
Bishop ending I know it's a draw with
the Rooks but with the Bishops as well
bearing in mind I mean I do feel that A5
is so weakening so bearing in mind that
black wants to play ah Wesley I'm too
long-winded in my explanation he played
A4 yes he didn't even allow uh the
possibility of B5 because the bishop can
actually if you're not careful
seek its way to H4 and
wait a minute of Larry Christmas or C5
C5 is also another possibility but
obviously not now right he wants to go
D5 right now right well I thought Bishop
F2 would have left maybe to that ending
of three versus two that you mentioned
but I'm seeing Bishop F2 and
I'm thinking you gotta play D5
and you've got to come back I'm assuming
to see tube because the pawn on B3 is
actually pretty tender
right so if you go Bishop C2 now is
black I want to put my bit yes
F2 no no no carry on carry on Bishop F2
and now you have to take back Bishop C5
yes I don't I want to trade on my terms
which means you capturing and you just
keep the tension as right to keep the
tension precisely yes I I think this is
the setup I think this is the drawing
the drawing setup right so anticipate
this is the current position right D5
takes takes we're anticipating Bishop C2
and then Jovi what were you about to say
sorry well I just wanted to check this
because White's King is mightily active
so I mean the most forcing move is
Bishop takes Bishop okay
and then F5 F5 yeah you know get the
king to E5 okay there
and I see you uh and I don't like it I
don't like your king getting anywhere
near that E5 Square so I'm gonna take it
away from you I appreciate that I've
given you a protected past Bond but what
do they say weaknesses are only weak if
you can if you can attack them
and by the way what let me do a refresh
because somehow I'm seeing a dark
squared Bishop he actually moved his
Bishop to A3 and uh well Wesley said
consequences my friend you put your
Bishop on A3 I'm gonna put my Bishop on
C3 use the diagonal that was not
available to me C5 Bishops on C5 Bishop
like I said I think all the Bishops are
really good it's it's kind of unusual to
see a position where every you know you
usually have a position where one player
has has a bad piece you know like
there's something wrong in the position
for a player in this particular case uh
F5 King F4 Still Still uh not complete
equality I wanted to say for Hikaru it's
that space Advantage yes so difficult to
get rid of right right
uh King f8 inviting F5 especially when
every time you try to gain some of that
space Advantage back with a move such as
D4 as black immediately the king gets to
E4 centralized grabbed the pawn on D4
that's going to be a bad bad evening
yeah
I was so it he's giving his King uh the
space the square pardon me
is getting getting interesting
certainly is
and uh Hikaru does feel like it's
groveling
so that's not a problem Hikaru still not
a problem you know just uh under 15
minutes whereas Wesley has 11 minutes so
he can take the time to think through
all the consequences okay here Jovi big
question you're recapturing with the
pawn
with the bishop
you don't want to give yourself a passer
nope no I want to make the H4 my pride
and joy
so you really like the outside right not
not the past F Pawn and the bishop on E5
is controlling the queening square that
makes a lot of sense but this is all
kind of very general concepts of course
well General but also quite specific for
the moment and the moment
defense H6
Bishop takes F5 we're expecting and
you're saying H6 why not
well
push push him baby that's age four let's
do it move by move H6 H4
I'll wait somehow
let's say Bishop B7
let's do
so I have to tickle down attack so now
I've got I've got ideas of Bishop to D4
back to C5 oh back to see oop excuse me
that was my mouse slip my bad
can I all right so how ask the question
you got pretty much everything you want
Bishop Texas
Shelby you're too good I'm gonna get
Chris bird to come in here and wand you
for chips
we want Fair commentary
our viewers want Fair commentary you got
to give them lengthen them you got to
give the boys a chance Bishop takes F5
H7 H6 keep going with adoration we might
actually go into that
um no he went Bishop F4 sorry Bishop F4
King G7 came instantly by the way
and a good thing because there was no
really other good move
they should be five king of faith
we might return to that variations
we're actually pushing a little bit here
right I mean it doesn't
and it's it's not a bland draw that's
for sure I mean hey it's a big battle of
wits so I I really like your ideas of H4
but by the way one thing that we did not
look at and maybe we should have what
about the counter spiel
under control
okay you have to take
it you don't want to see the bond
rushing that far up the board
and and now I'm assuming this right now
I'm now I'm thinking I should
engineer extra
trade
I want to say of light squared Bishops
and how is the situation I have no idea
age five you're asking
the right person the wrong person see
some checks
wow
this has to be a draw right well he has
played H4 and we might be seeing this
very line the counter Spiel with D4
I kind of wanna
wait for you to go G5 first so
one line that we looked at with the
bishop E7
Bishop T
7 first yes Bishop to E7 G3 I go back I
wait for you to go G5 okay the working
is a bit further away and now comes the
canvas feel and I do
also also I want to ask you guys the
question say you let the pawn live on D3
so go Bishop C2 right you go D3 and I'm
like I don't care wow
my the idea is just to kind of like roll
the king towards the center obviously
and just round up the D3 Pawn well uh
good for the goose good for the gander
how you know well we're gonna we're
gonna find out because Hikaru is not not
waiting for white to rock and roll and
the King side he says I've got my trumps
as well d
D4
and this is plain old honorary counter
chance uh Bishop takes B3
Bishop to C2 most likely we're going to
see now
what I like about these top players is
they don't just automatically play the
most obvious move right how many games
have they probably saved or won by just
pausing finding the situations by being
an improvement you know a little tickle
here maybe make all the difference in
the world like Bishop F4 look at this
h 5 what take the pawn what
Bishop takes B3 and what's the IDE so G5
wow you have Bishop
wow okay okay just eight let's okay
what's let's go let's go to G3 right
his idea is
what what were you saying about the
queening square the promotion Square the
Bishops are escorting the pawn to a
coronation okay now you're like you
cannot take on
I was about to say that looks like it
could lose the game
now that's a nice fine that's Mari The
Waters by West really and fine oh my
goodness and in the meanwhile
a move light King E4 and G5 is
definitely on White's agenda hello
that's
okay now
sorry a Christian has the game suddenly
become exceedingly sharp for hakaru
don't take on B3 yeah it's a narrow path
yes don't don't take on B3 don't skip
the bishop on F7 as is keep contact with
the pawn on C5 go King G8
that makes a lot of sense and is the
idea of the G5 that's a check that's a
check yeah so we've gotta we've gotta uh
prep G5 with the move King G3 now can I
go
I cannot go Bishop
actually I can perhaps take on B3 first
and now when you go G5 I can go Beach
Buffet
wow
it feels like it feels like uh you're on
the edge there is a really nice trick in
the position the D4 yeah and now I say
oh I'm taking on A4 and I'm connecting
my passers oh no no no no not yet Bishop
B6 King H7 G6 mate be careful don't fall
into this type of Case by the way it's a
commentator's job to show all the
potential checkmating patterns because
as we know Checkmate ends the game right
and we this is the current position
we're looking at
a line of play
for Wesley
that could potentially win the game King
G3 how will it go after King G3 uh
Christian what does the engine say if it
goes triple zeros
I mean this is such a tense game with so
many possibilities and the computers
like I'm not impressed yeah Special B3
G5 Bishop fate only move Bishop B3
G5 Bishop
so I can take this pawn and then I will
take on G5 basically after Bishop f8
might let's say a mini thread is to take
on G5 now that you don't have H6 gotcha
so you take on D4 I take on G5 you take
on B6 I take on A4 then basically we
simplify everything okay
Psy but King Jade is not easy I mean
it's a very passive move right right and
you can start seeing ghosts definitely
you see those type of checkmates that
we've just shown you start getting
scared or at least worried also you're
moving the king away from the action so
after KN G8 say for instance you also
have to calculate Bishop C2 that's right
right and continue from there that's
right yeah yeah and that's exactly what
Hikaru is doing
by the way just breaking news that
Fabiano
are 2022 American Cup champion showing
his blitzkills is he is a comfortable
one point ahead of a chasing pack of
wolves yes as we go into the last final
two rounds right now
that's a big win that's a very big win
because Ray has got a formidable Blitz
reputation here in the St Louis circles
I know he's playing Lanier Dominguez
with the black pieces in round eight you
know it's just amazing how all those top
guys always are hovering at the top
isn't it yeah well they do say cream
always Rises to the top it's true and
the Crematory
played by Hikari you know he took his
time to come to that decision he did
it's a good one
it's the best one yeah G8 uh by the way
that that whole
idea of Bishop f8 it's not intuitively
obvious that you want to go backwards
but by playing the move King G8 and
allowing this move Bishop f8 in
anticipation of G5
very nice I just I mean you know very
very nice this is one of those games
that you study whenever you
learn about these structures and try to
get a deeper understanding of these
structures and you're thinking hey I
could potentially end in this particular
ad game this is how I have to defend it
and you look at this game it's one of
those history books type event games
exactly by the way can I take can I take
a different approach we've just seen the
move D3 anticipating Bishop takes D3
Bishop takes B3 I'll put my Bishop on B5
basically saying your your Pawn
structure on the queen side is fixed
you're not doing anything and maybe on a
good day I'll be able to I'll stay
connected to the iPhone on G4 Bishop B6
Bishop E6 you'll stay connected to the
pawn on G4 guys I don't want to allow
you to go something like Bishop D4 in
one and
which before King G7 King G7 and uh
huh
you know what I'm Dreaming right but I
want I want to fix the king side but I
want to do it in such a way that I can
do you know what the problem printing to
B6 so with the bishop B5 the only way to
defend both the pawn on G4 and the pawn
on H5
sorry the pawn on A4 and the pawn on G4
is from D1 exactly but then once you get
there I go Bishop D7 B5 it change the
last Pawn on the queen side and that's a
draw that's exactly you can also get
there by D7 but uh obviously Hikaru will
keep a tight watch on that square
so you mean sorry right here you know
you can't be
quite careless and you can't pay for
instance play a random move like I said
oh Bishop I'd say king is that it's a
silly move exactly pure Bishop on this
beauty and then I do have dreams right
right exactly that's that's key that's
why
uh
Christian was quick to suggest them with
Bishop E6 and keep me tethered oh by the
way you're Bishop D1 was Wesley has made
an appearance on the board exactly
them's fighting words
now Jovi I want you to speak a little
bit softer so the players can't hear it
uh Bishop D1 and Coach jump in what
what's what's happening here the game is
really getting uh sharp because the king
wants to go to E4 Bishop D5 stop the
king from going to E4 but now the king
wants to go to F5 which he does but now
what if I go King to F7 okay here's the
F7 I want to go back to five King side
the check right
change the narrative
no more King E4 yeah
what Bishop E3 Bishop Edgar three yes
okay
now again I didn't know which was the
good Bishop I didn't know what was the
bad Bishop this is the first time I get
an opportunity to trade Bishop I take
you take can you take that's fine so you
get that part
I've got a bad Bishop but I've got a bad
Bishop defending good pawns and now I go
Bishop C6
and I munch munch I go B5
Munch back now the king steps up
now are you in time
because my intention uh Christian just
to flag you uh I know was not to allow
you to trade your Bishop for the a pawn
I know your mean intentions right well
aware of that yes so if you played for
example King here I will go there yeah
Bishop D7 or what is pH yeah uh my
intention
was to go B4 now how do I do it Joby if
I go here I step in front of the pawn
that's not what I want we do have King
H7 on the board uh
has the engine changed its opinion about
the zeros no not yet not yet white still
has a slight pool but it's not enough
it's one of those it's one of those 0.2
that means that white is just enjoying a
space Advantage okay
and uh how narrow is the path
for Hikaru
not that narrow he has like for example
even in the last move King F7 or King H7
over both making a draw as long as you
don't allow that King to come to E4
centralize itself like that then you're
more or less fine but
you know as the time control gets lower
as you reach those last couple of
minutes right then you start getting
worried
yeah so the way it works is as your flag
keeps going higher and higher that's the
time to panic
that's what coaches teach you know I was
once played on an Olympic team in
Istanbul and our team captain was uh
Nick defer me and we had a captains
meeting before the game and Nick said
okay guys you know
develop your pieces Castle early put
your king in safety stay ahead on the
clock and we were like listening to our
coach and nodding our head like why do
you think anything else coach you know
you could you check all the boxes you
know so and go get them tiger yes Bishop
C3 this what was your experience of
experiences I really want to say my
rivals in the U.S Championship I've
never met such nice guys when we were
playing in the U.S Championship I hated
them all
but when we're on the team together
wow I mean everybody is rooting for one
another and it's just a completely
different
um setup I mean it's great and uh yeah I
I've played I think about 10 Olympics
and two world team championships and I
do like team events I find them more
stressful than individual events they're
very stressful because if you mess up
yeah you mess up for everybody exactly
and you feel it but it's very important
not to have that mindset you just have
to say you know I we work as a team so
if I lose someone has to cover if you're
right by the way Bishop G2 on the board
keeping an eye over the E4 square but
potentially allowing King E5 and
Bishop D4 anything anything there comes
up F3 right now wait a minute Bishop F3
how is that one well I've been I I
didn't know which pair of Bishops to
trade but
this is the first time I get a chance to
even make such a noise
Bishop F1 came instantly no no trades
for you but now King E4
well you can put your Bishop on E2 sorry
I I thought you might be running out of
moves
there's an interesting idea try to get
closer to the bishop with King G3
King to Jesus
not sure where I'm going though but wait
one second so there you go King we were
looking at King E4 which I like yes and
you were suggesting Bishop B2 oh I'm
wondering
the greedy Pig In Me Goes Bishop takes
Bishop good for you yes excellent I love
it this is we can play Bishop E2 I
apologize that was my bad and that's why
I want to go King G3
because my plan is after King goes to G3
I go Bishop D1 next then I follow that
up with King F3
and then I go King to E4
dude why didn't you just put your King
on e4 and your Bishop on D1 right away
because you're not in time I go
before
sorry what I go Bishop B4 if you go King
to E4 first okay yeah
and Bishop takes I'm still confused I
take and take King E3 right and now I'm
perhaps in time right I go King G7
whoa whoa whoa this is way this is quite
the race now we calculate King F6
perhaps Bishop E2 wait a minute right I
have Bishop I think Bishop E2 good for
you okay because boy for a minute there
I thought I was faster on the queen side
I'm still not yeah I'm still not 100 I'm
sure either but uh in the meantime wow
is uh
three and a half ways getting closer
three and a half minutes whereas uh
Hikaru is just around the five minute
foot by the way I really think the game
is turning the the there's opportunities
here uh that have suddenly appeared
after this move Bishop to F1 I like your
what you were saying about King G3 G3
you only have one oh what now the path
is starting to get very more narrow okay
Bishop to E3 is your only move only only
move and after your Bishop D1 idea after
Bishop D1 you have to go back you have
to wait for me no I get the king to F3
okay
and now once again you have to be very
precise let's go Bishop H3
Bishop a
this does not look like the move of
precision uh the space three uh
Christian
and then go back to F1 and try to
survive like this
wow not easy very very strange move
because again the bishop looks so
forlorn over here like what are you
doing there
makes no sense to me this either either
I'm wondering oh my well it's Wesley
who's going under three minutes suddenly
I thought that he had
time not anymore Jovi what are the times
well now you know I did say that Wesley
had just around about three and a half
minutes he's used a whole chunk of that
and now he's down to two minutes Hikaru
still on the 5 minute 45 second mark
I must say I mean I had this move on my
mind from way back I I understood that
Bishop D1 King F3 or now guys he has to
go Bishop is that the only move in the
position you're not the only move but
the uh the second G8 he didn't do it
I wasn't going yeah King G8 is not an
easy move to make bishop to D it was the
second best seven
Bishop C3 check
just to gain some time Wesley's playing
it like the professional he is gaining a
little time on the clock but how do we
round up how do we win material
that's my my question
so back Bishop back to D2 Bishop to E3
Bishop to E3 or Bishop to F4 okay Bishop
to E3 Bishop Bishop
here Bishop F4
sorry Jeffy jumping yeah I was going to
say Bishop D2 and there is the idea of
what walking the cane to see
C4 and then rocking up that way the
problem I I'd love to Simply go here
right but if I lose
too much contact there's going to be a
bishop E2 that's going to miss me in
other words my king goes to wandering
too far I've got to deal with Bishop E2
as a consequence King back to G7 maybe
we're gonna see G5
well at some point you probably have to
be before he's just playing playing the
engine right now really putting a lot of
pressure on Hikaru okay
anything
can I get away with Bishop E2 now you
can try yeah Bishop let's go G5
uh then you play G5
yeah don't ask me why
I was about to ask you why sorry about
that
and uh Wesley now around 1 minute 35
seconds but it's Hikaru who's feeling
the pressure uh as well on the position
because let's move Bishop F4
hmm I mean you King can't move the
bishop on F1 kind of Tethered to the
pawn on D3 the bishop on B6 pardon me
the bishop on C5 is guarding the pawn on
B6 you start to feel uncomfortable when
you feel you're running out of moves I
think Hikaru seems to be reaching for
the bishop and putting it on B4
it does often rules threatened D2 is it
a big threat though Bishop to B4 I
understand Bishop B4 Bishop E3
challenging you to play the move D2 my
Bishop on F3
you do have Bishop G2
nasty
Bishop F2 whoa
okay once again he's kind of inviting
these Bishop trades
and this bishop is kind of trapped on
the F1 square right
Bishop E3
Bishop takes E3 King takes E3 King F6
um
I think you're in time I do too I I I
suddenly realize that that I'm gonna
have to play King
F2 and King G3 and make a draw Bishop B5
is what Wesley seems to be getting ready
for Bishop E5 and anything to be said
for G4 G5 and just making sure that
that's that would be a good move
uh in fact the best move according to
the engine but Bishop E5 also makes a
lot of sense
Bishop E5 King F7 played quickly Hikaru
wants to keep the pressure on Wesley
putting some pressure on his clock yes
yes and by the way I mean we understand
that the engine is saying white is
better but that d-pawn if you get down
to your last few seconds and you make a
wrong move
could go down the board yes exactly
don't forget it is a it is a passer
after all it's a huge Bishop back to uh
C3 stopping the pawn and again I have to
ask you about the clocks so uh Wesley
one and a half minutes 50 seconds 50
seconds right now 50 seconds is what it
is sorry my apologies okay yeah looking
at the clock um yeah is plenty of plenty
of time three minutes four minutes right
something like that four minutes and 42
seconds okay
so Hikaru has done what we always
expected him to do stay ahead on the
clock but the position seems to offer
Wesley's son some chances
of uh it's easy to go wrong
C5
just returning again I think Bishop to
D2 just to gain
um
Wesley seemed uncertain did you see that
he just held back from pressing the
clock for a full second or two you know
I suspect he did a quick blunder check
just to make sure nothing was awry
I see that in Scholastics where the
little kids keep their finger on top of
the piece you know
Bishop E1 again are you going to tell me
Triple zeros uh Christian of course of
course
why do I even ask
not yet three four zeros but it's 0.1 if
you go Bishop B4 okay
again is Bishop B4 the only
move I know it's the best one no no no
no Bishop before is the only move to
keep this 0.1 if you go King G7 maybe
that's 0.8 but it doesn't really matter
it doesn't seem like white has a clear
path forward the position
I have to say I think Bishop before is
not going to happen because it kind of
changes the Dynamics right it seems like
Hikaru has been playing Bishop King G7
Bishop G1 kind of moves he's been
reluctant to offer trade of Bishops I
think he's going to go for it oh he's
nodding his head that's that's King to
Jesus
see see by the way uh you were in Berlin
where they're measuring the heart rates
but it just feels like this is a moment
where the heart rate seems to have
popped up uh a Beat
or two
whoa he's oh he's claiming a draw he's
claiming a repetition I'm guessing with
the move King to G7 okay so this is what
I think that Hikaru should do he should
say I claim a draw with the move King G7
Arbiter Chris bird will go and check
that the claim is accurate now let's
imagine that the claim is inaccurate yes
oh the players have agreed to a draw
I've checked it's accurate it is
accurate it is accurate yes but imagine
that it was inaccurate Wesley would get
a minute that's the worst thing just a
minute and then Hikaru gets the
information that it has been two times
already and then he can parlay that
forward
intriguing it is intriguing a lot of
questions remained unanswered but we do
have one more uh final round in the
blitz portion so perhaps we could go
there
but as we jump to the chase let's remind
our viewers uh we do have two draws the
players will continue the playoff
exactly and we're going to now play an
accelerated rapid format of uh two game
10 minute plus five second increment and
as we saw yesterday Wesley was
resplendent in this time control so it'd
be interesting to see how it goes
let's have a look at how Alice Lee is
doing in the blitz against hausa elshon
of course played in the U.S
championships uh last year and uh well
Alice is crossing swords with some of
America's Finest in the Blitz
how is she doing in the competition do
we know that
I will have our crack production team
get on these key questions right away
and yeah it's one of those classic
Bishop versus knight setups look at her
go with the bud vinic Rook A2 Rook E2 F4
learning from her game against atusa
percussion in game one exactly but I do
think we should probably move to the
Fabiano versus uh around Jacobian game
because that's the championship game
that's the championship game that's the
championship game this is the last round
Fabiano is leading in the competition
around with a potential Victory could
maybe catch up to the leader dang
that it's not an easy position
no I don't have the position sorry about
that
there it is hold on is this
that's the position but it's a
completely different board exam it looks
ugly
my eyes are hurting they're hurting okay
we're gonna just stay with the bird's
eye view I'm gonna keep it there
by the way pagliano with the black
pieces with the black piece extra minute
on the clock and I see
I see a a Wiki on the C4 Square yes you
see we're putting that point up very
soon
as Tweety Bird would say
is he a pretty tat it seems like Fabiano
might be clinching the title of how do
we call this tournament again the
American Cup Blitz yeah that's that's an
easy one
we didn't want to confuse anybody uh by
the way does he have a one-point lead
coming into this game or a half a point
lead what would set it up for us I want
to say half a point but I do not have uh
the official standings
one
so my guess is that levonne was probably
one point behind him and now he's half a
point behind him that's just a guess
okay
educated guess last move was C5 just
giving that Bishop the boot from the
long diagonal
Fabiano playing very classical and
very pure and very green chess that Rook
ad1 move is desirable as it looks would
have allowed might be too with a pretty
nasty Fork
so uh Queen C2 a little bit uh
walk uh quiet let's say D5 black black
is more than equalized probably is just
no no upon up is much better pardon me
yes apology he's completely winning
right now oh yeah no no no sorry I I
didn't realize he was actually enjoying
a material and positional advantage
yeah yeah and also a clock Advantage as
well uh but white has just 20 seconds
and now another important game
[Music]
we see a ram not very happy we're not
happy at all his positions
popping his head into the
into the position and what with
16 seconds
A4 that's another Pawn dropping well
that is a delicious spawn on A4 at least
the root gets to E7 okay enjoy the
temporary happiness
A5 let's go and the bishop will will
either go to C2 to I like it on C2
because it I like it controls it
controls the night I want to go okay big
threat of the board of 97 of course Fabi
sees this one again if you played Bishop
to C2 there would have been no Knight F5
there would have been no
no fun but what about Rook A8 now good
good spot
nicely done that was a solution that
probably five might be A4 might be
winning but you know no need to play
with your food yeah yeah no need to play
to the crowd
okay and by the way uh the next
game of the championship coming up we'll
be starting at 4 30.
right and our congratulations is to Fabi
will get a confirmation on that but I do
think he won the event again absolutely
yeah on that position he won the event
and
in the key game between Wesley so and
Hikaru makamura they are now moving on
to the two-game rapid playoff where
they're playing 10 minutes plus five
second increments the match is still
tied we're gonna move on to the blitz
playoff and finally it's a little bit of
a Marmite solution but everything will
be decided by an Armageddon game I'm
going to ask you about malmite but I
want to remind everybody that Wesley won
his playoff in the next set of Rapid
games coming up and it was in the blitz
that won his player
and well let's have a look at Wesley's
path to the top and he well he beat Sam
and then he faced off against Fabiana
karona it was a win in the end for
Wesley and then he met Hikaru and
Nakamura with the Champions bracket and
that much it was Hikaru that was
triumphants knocking Wesley down went to
the arms of LeBron aronian well also
went to tie breaks there but Wesley so
shut up to the Grand Final against
Hikaru Nakamura now yesterday they
played a big match and Wesley so was in
a must-win situation Wesley has said hey
guys they get no free days and we'll see
why he's played a total of 22 games
that's a lot six wins 13 draws three
losses and wow
that's a lot of games it's a lot of
games I I wouldn't have guessed that and
I have to say Wesley just keeps playing
better and better I mean he said to him
he said to us you know that he's been
playing for two months straight right
from he's hard to steal to do so you
wouldn't have guessed it from this last
match he feels fresh
and yes we're going to take a quick
break and we'll be back
um well we'll be back and uh shortly
with action from both playing Halls
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess is
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
five hundred dollars
another top three finishers in third
place with six and a half points
Grandmaster Lanier Dominguez three
thousand dollars
includers second with seven and a half
points goes to Grandmaster Lavon our
road is four thousand salad
and the winner of their American Cup lit
for five thousand dollars Grandmaster
Fabiano
[Applause]
congratulations to all the winners we'll
we'll be uh sending out checks or uh
quarterman
direct deposits
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to the final between in
the American Cup 2023 is Championship
Sunday and so far it's Even Stevens
between Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura
nothing is separating these two players
and that means that they are playoff
bound and they are now going to play
this accelerated playoff format of 10
minutes plus five seconds per move which
is the exact time control that
um
Wesley capitalized upon to win his
playoff against Hikaru
and Hikaru capitalized on the game three
plus two which stands to come thereafter
yes I mean I I suspect this next playoff
is going to be full of excitement right
it's gonna you're gonna see the players
just fight it out in a real slugfest as
they've done previously
and in case all of those games are drawn
then they would play the single
Armageddon match and we're expecting 430
Central uh time for that match to begin
but in the meanwhile we have two games
that we wanted to set you up for from
the blitz tournament that we just saw
earlier and there was one game in
particular that we're going to set you
up for and that's it was a round seven
game between Sam Sauvignon and the
voluntaroni and a kind of a rematch if
you will from the American Cup and here
the players go this is not live this is
a sad to say an instant replay and
they're ah and uh English but um because
level was the one who eliminated Sam
Savion exactly from the competitions
exactly which is personal really
personal and a2a3 inviting a reverse
Sicilian and G7 G6 ducking the
the challenge
now everybody's castled but now the
question is yes do I play D7 D6 and
those positions or do I play the move D5
is the Pawn on E5 hanging
[Music]
um
I take on C3 I take on C6 I take on D1
you take on d8 and I think I take on B2
and perhaps which is fine but B7 is
hanging you should take on B7 as well
this is what he's calculating yeah
absolutely this is definitely what he's
calculating right now Knight takes E5
it's still a pertinent question
and my guess is that Levon given the
fact that he hasn't spent any time
from his initial clock probably knows
what and after some thinking Sam decided
to duck the issue entirely played the
move D to D3 and by the way this was all
uh preparation it is Lavon because this
is still Theory Knight takes C5 is an
option but it doesn't lead to anything
good for white T3 is the most timid move
but still keeping the position very
complex and again we have a reversed
Sicilian
um
these double fee and Shadow complexes
that come out of that oftentimes and
here we go a night lands in the center
of the board Knight D4 and what black
tries to do is encourage Knight takes D4
and he wants to recapture with the pawn
and use the half open e-file by playing
moves like rookie 8 and Knight D5 as a
way of putting pressure on E2 but uh in
the meantime the trade has happened and
the Knight has found itself on e4
could spring to C5 at the right time
yeah well I mean again Knight D5 rookie
8 C7 C6 these are all happy moves I can
find pretty
routinely uh but especially C6 right
pardon me especially C6 especially C6
where black because that's such a
typical move in this type of structures
you close up the bishopon G2 which is
the most uh threatening piece right
White's camp and you're also getting
more or less rid of the weakness on C7
that the Rokon C1 is set up against
now there it is kind of a a funny Point
mostly as white you do want to play B4
B5 yes you know and and kind of make a
wedge against the pawn on C7 the problem
is that sometimes when you do play this
whole B4 B5 stuff the square C3 can
sometimes be weak and F7 F5 and Knight
C3 well I have to say this is a bit
strange yeah
giving me a Tempo and then going back to
C2 it does make a lot of sense I see the
move C7 C6 is very useful for black
thank you very much and here I would be
very tempted to play A5 and if you allow
it A4 that's what he's going for A5
what's per broadcast yeah once per
broadcast these guys are very good
and you can see one on the board
there you go okay Lavon is going to be
pleased with uh setting up the blue
that's a crafty move isn't it uh he
shows his veteran skills there with that
one time for white to initiate action on
the wings
he's put his Knight on C5 he's on the
board right
over there
who who will lie to B5 193.
okay but why is that so cool Bishop E6
just testing you uh whether you're gonna
take a draw
again for those who are joining us late
this is a game that was played at the
blitz tournament just concluded at the
chase Hotel here in St Louis Missouri in
the Central West End uh Sam Savion with
the white pieces against Lavon aronian
you think this is the one moment where
we should probably try to trick our
audience and tell them that this is life
no that's not and we are waiting for uh
the playoff finals
and Sam said no my repetition no
repetition for you Knight A5 tickling B7
okay how I I would play either rookie
yeah I like Rook A7 inviting Bishop C6
but I want I definitely want to play the
move Bishop D5 Joby
but I don't want to lose my B7 pawn and
queen E7 crafty move and uh well this
Knight has just danced around the whole
board you know E4 it's gone C5 B3 hey oh
what a journey
okay uh Lavon didn't want to allow Rook
takes B5 I don't know if it was a big
threat or not he just didn't even want
to allow it so he played 96 rookie yes
and I feel it's time to start softening
up the black king side do you you've
been aspiring H4 uh for some time right
do you think about Bishop C6 is Bishop
takes C6 on your agenda
just because because you know I feel
like
Barry very reluctant
reluctable the part with the light
Square Bishop but Bishop C6 does have
this idea of Knight takes C6 you get two
pawns but uh Bishop F3 I think I can see
what he's doing
right there yeah you don't oftentimes
see Lavon doing that when Lavon reaches
and makes a move he usually certain and
perhaps this is the idea of this bishop
to F3 to go H4 H5 support that move and
that's why Lavon plays this movie Bishop
to H3 stop H4 but also put that King in
some sort of Danger on G1 well Jovi
would have said well in that case play
H4 immediately and that don't allow
Bishop H3 yes
and to see would you throw in a dummy
dummy what
what are you doing extending the
diagonal of the light squared Bishop
right
okay the queen and the Rook lining up on
the C file does allow for this move Rook
C7 going down the wire 20 seconds for
Levon 23 for sets well Rook D7 uh let's
go I don't know
Queen F6 inviting Knight takes B7 with
the tempo Against The Rook I guess Levon
is not worried 15 seconds
okay now there's a big threat of course
it takes the queen taste Bishop on the
board I was about to say it sure was you
want to you don't want to allow Queen F3
that would have been an embarrassing
I I thought he might play Bishop to D5
but nope well Knight C5
the night it has done a grand tour by
the way that night has been all over the
place
and
whoa whoa whoa whoa oh that was a check
apologies
for Sam
getting ready to play that move F5
destabilized Knight only four three
seconds
[Music]
three two okay how do you defend that
Knight on D6 now and bring the queen in
queen queen after d a there's no more
move right oh and he Flags
and he spotted it immediately he he knew
that flag oh
Sam must be thinking why do I have this
guy as an opponent he knocks me out of
the American Cup now he beats me in the
blitz yes ruins my child says well I
don't know what they did but right well
it didn't help his chance was much more
darn sure
and we actually have the winner of the
tournament with us in the studio with
Christian Fabi welcome back to the show
the American Cup did finish but you did
win the American Cup Blitz portion of
the event that last bit about this
tournament yeah I think I played three
sections in this tournament first I
played in the Champions bracket then the
elimination bracket and then the
basement bracket
that's amazing and tell us what do you
feel was your most difficult opponent in
this one it felt we were watching the
results pile up but it and it felt quite
smooth for you did you feel the same way
overall I think I played well and it was
relatively smooth
um definitely the toughest game was
against left because
I was much worse than I was winning I
think and then I made a very bad
decision and then I had to suffer in a
very unpleasant endgame
uh so that was probably the toughest
game and after that it was it was pretty
smooth I think I played a really good
game against Sam Shanklin that was maybe
my best game I I didn't have a chance to
check with the engine of course what uh
if there were some big mistakes but
but that felt like a good game
and then yeah this game against linear
was the most important one in fact we do
have the end of that game the one
between yourself and Lanier the most
important game for you let's take a look
at that
and that's truly the end of it that
really is the end of the game
let's have a look at that again
it was quick yeah producers are uh yeah
playing mind games
uh guys join the conversation well first
of all uh tell us uh your your
perspective of the match between Wesley
so and Hikaru how do you see this
playing out we've got the playoffs
coming up of game 10 and 5 Seconds who
do you like
yeah I actually don't know I mean it
really is very close to 50 50. they
played a bunch of matches in the past
year where they went pretty much down to
the wire I feel like Wesley is probably
playing a bit better at the moment
although he did lose the first match
that they played went to elimination
then one not to get eliminated but I
felt like he was he was outplaying Him
in all the matches and then Hikaru is uh
super resourceful when it comes down to
the last few seconds
so um
if it gets to Blitz yeah probably Hikaru
should be a favorite
but
um yeah it's going to be so close and
also these games these matches of two
games you know they're always a tussle
Jody
no I was going to ask Fabiano
um
so do you think it would make an impact
that Hikaru lost his match against
Wesley tomorrow
yeah for sure that that puts momentum in
Wesley's favor uh that's a big blow
because I'm sure Hikaru wanted to end it
yesterday and also to play The Blitz
today
uh so I mean of course he's he's going
to to fight very hard anyway it's not
like he's going to collapse
psychologically but the momentum
definitely shifted Wesley's favor after
that
one of the things that was striking to
my eyes was when we compared their live
ratings and in Blitz it was actually
Hikaru number two Wesley all the way to
number 19. do you feel that that is the
big discrepancy that might decide this
match well I think Blitz ratings are
also very volatile you have one bad
event and any raiding tanks um like
Hikaru I think gained this 2900 rating
because in the last year in the St Louis
um
uh rap and Blitz he he basically
it was he and Ali Reza they both kind of
ran away with it but Ali Reza had the
better Rapids so so he won the
tournament but Hikaru was like basically
winning all his Blitz Games that he car
also did well in the world championship
I think he got silver
but uh but his 2900 was gained in that
rapid bullets last year and I don't know
where Wesley lost his rating but you
know these with blitz sometimes you you
lose a lot in one tournament because
it's like if you're in bad form you can
lose you know 50 100 points in a day it
doesn't really happen in classical and
and likewise you can also win a ton of
rating so
um I wouldn't say that there's like a
huge qualitative difference between car
and Wesley of course Hikaru should be by
results the better Blitz player but it's
going to be a very slight difference and
it could depend a lot on you know the
Forum on that particular day how they're
feeling mentally if they slept enough
things like that you know this players
so well and one thing that we've seen
with Wesley whenever he plays this ten
plus five he usually goes down to his
last three four minutes very often he
car was on eight nine minutes and then
he starts speeding up in the middle game
and he really puts a lot of pressure
with precise moves in the middle game
tell us a bit about that how do you see
it yeah I've noticed that Wesley really
really tries to avoid severe time travel
like very uh consistently as opposed to
other players like let's say Levon or
linear especially they don't they don't
shy away from time pressure as much
Wesley I think realizes that he he loses
control even if you're even if you're
super strong you're going to lose
control and time pressure and he tries
to avoid that smell Ariel and we saw
that when he was beating Nakamura
objectively winning and that that
absolutely crazy game that he lost
um when I sacrificed The Rook at the end
yeah yeah I mean the game was crazy and
actually very impressive up to that
point and then it was like in kind of
inexplicable decision to take on E6 yeah
but uh he was winning and he was out
playing Hikaru and then once he got down
to seconds and Hikaru of course is
probably the best in the world at these
sort of things like setting up chances
and tricks I think he and he and Magnus
like the this B3 and uh trying to set up
some sort of uh even if it's not
objectively the the best setting up some
sort of potential shots potential that
if things go wrong for white then they
really go wrong and that's what happened
um and Wesley once he got down to
seconds he couldn't keep control of the
situation which I mean I can also relate
to uh very often also lose control when
I'm down to my last two seconds of last
few seconds
so so he's trying to avoid that for sure
while Hikaru I think he he is incredibly
strong like if it's just time scramble
he's definitely better than Wesley Fabi
we're not going to see you here in St
Louis for a while what's next for you in
the next couple of months well I'll be
in St Louis you just won't see me I'm
always sticking around for a bit and
then I have like the grandchild's tour
starts
um also we'll probably be doing
something for the world championship
uh not not playing of course
unfortunately but talking about it uh
discussing the match uh so that'll be
fun and then the the grand chess tour
starts first uh Bucharest and then like
all the tournaments start again it's
going to be kind of hectic hectic
schedule awesome congratulations for the
victory in the blitz event we'll see you
soon thanks
thank you uh fappi for joining us uh
very much indeed ensuring your thoughts
on this playoff that's coming up because
once again I see this next series of
games these two games coming up as being
Wesley's chance like he's wanted this
time control he's outplayed Hikaru at
this time control whereas the three plus
two I fear really favors Hikaru and this
is what we're talking about he'll be
right here right now we're on the top of
that playoff it certainly is because
their players will be playing two-game
rapid playoff at a time control of 10
minutes plus five second increment and
just going back to those earlier
matchups where they were fighting for
Championship bracket winner right I
remember these two traded blows with
each other and when Wesley had to win on
Demand with the black thesis and just
yesterday not tomorrow as I
[Laughter]
Wesley was convincing yeah in that
particular format right exactly and
that's uh well the two playoffs uh and
well this is the decider coming up and
uh for me I wanted to say that uh I had
chose Wesley as my pick
because I saw him as being consistent in
the classical chess consistent in the
Rapids and consistent at this time
control as well ten plus five I I Hikaru
is a generational Talent where Blitz and
lightning
[Music]
[Laughter]
and wow okay uh well well again I mean
yeah well I mean you know uh Christian
had to go with his people
otherwise he would have beaten him and
in the trainings uh
yeah I'm sure you will I wanted to ask
um uh Bobby we have enjoyed this format
tremendously and I hope our audiences
have as well because it gives us so much
action to call whether it be the blitz
going on the eliminations the the
Champions bracket and what have you but
this format has been used for the
American Cup stop but would Fabby like
to see this format used in events like
the national championship that would
have would have been a question I would
like to ask because I'd love to see this
format used more often as Wesley joins
the table it does it's the shoes it's
all about the shoes it is only about the
shoes and Hikaru obviously just setting
the board and simply getting into the
Zone visualizing the perfect outcome and
they are off honestly opens with E4 and
we're going to see another Berlin
because that last Berlin even though
Berlin No Berlin Wesley had a little
little pressure at the end but not
enough to really scare Hikaru away and
we have a Joko piano yeah Wesley kind of
falling back on his chessable course yes
I have 287 shying away from any sort of
d-force and I must admit that my brain
turns to Mush because there's now in
this moment they play the move A5 and
somehow that's you know really really
clever and I have no explanations as to
why it's so clever this is a very
classical way of in fact playing The
Joker piano black is just trying to get
Bishop to E6 exchange light score
Bishops go and play for it D5 at the
right moment right white is going to try
to say okay you can play your D5 I will
try to uh do something on the queen side
this is exactly what we're seeing I
wanted to say I've seen Wesley be
playing the B4 systems with Bishop takes
E6 F takes E6 Bishop B2
um
you said it very well Christian yourself
earlier you said these guys know each
other and they know the positions so
incredibly well
it can't surprise one another and this
is still a very long Theory and very
well known at their level yeah there's
been many games in fact and I have to
say that it's all looking relatively
actually why it doesn't have a very
good score here actually
after hikari's last move wow just look
at this yes hikara must have just played
three moves in less than a second he
went like 96 97 96 Knight H7 it's as if
to say uh Chris Littlejohn and I have
been looking at this position all day
long
and it's now incumbent upon you to play
the move Knight F5 so I can show you my
homework but 93 was the novelty in this
game no kidding everybody was playing C4
in that position with an iPhone F1
trying to stop black from going D5 and
immediately after Knight G3 Hikaru
played the move Knight H7 but why not
make the break D5 why not go for it I
mean look you've done everything you
wanted you've reshuffled your knight
from C6 where it was getting hit with B5
all the way to G6 the same setup
defending the pawn on E5 very important
so you can still go D5 right now you
have the perfect setup you're ready to
go for break go for it
did not and again he played it instantly
as if he was still in his preparation
Knight H7 white decided okay if you're
not going to play for D5 I've got to do
something I'll cut your Bishop out of
the game I'll play the move d4 myself
and Knight G5 I mean I don't know about
hikaru's time time management is
definitely impressive the problem is
objectively right now he's making really
shaky moves really he's getting in a
worse position slowly but surely and
we've seen this happening in this
particular matchup between these two
players why what is it about White's
position that he could strike I don't I
can get the perfect setup right now so I
already already got D4 I already have a
space advantage in the center so yes
right now what I can do is take on G5
which he has done
Now what is my worst piece at least
moment the bishop exactly let's reroute
it to E3 a much more active solution and
then I mean I'm going to wait for you
hey what are you going to do next so
Bishop C1 Bishop E3 I like that journey
I like that too isn't Black's plan just
simply to
Park a night on F4 you can do that sure
but if you do that I will probably take
that Knight on F4 also the Knight on F4
without the help of any other piece in
the position
what is that night going to do by the
way boldly boldly pointing out the
obvious do not touch this deep Pawn
because Queen takes G3
might hurt so don't do that but Bishop
C1 followed by Bishop to E3 and as
Christian to say you're taking your
worst place piece and you're putting it
right back in the thick of things
with Bishop C1 perhaps this is some sort
of like super deep preparation by Hikaru
because he is blitzing every single one
of his every move is coming at this
point but it would shock me if that was
the case I think he just confused his
opening preparation right now after
Bishop to C1 he's in a worse position
Bishop C1 Bishop E3
um Wesley is not picked up on it nope
not yet Queen to G4 he did not sense
opportunity there and him play Queen G4
uh Joey I I liked what you were saying
like you want to park your night on F4
you want to go Rook G6 you want to gnash
your teeth and threaten you know
something so I would find myself drawn
to the move Queen G4 just to you know
like I don't know Force the queen back
and uh this move has actually caused
Hikaru to take his first pause in the
game right doubtlessly he's thinking
should I allow the trade of queens and
allow the Joe V rule uh when I'm
attacking uh to come into play uh I see
that from White's point of view white
would light more space
and with the Quake with the trade of
Queens I'm not afraid of getting
checkmated in anytime soon but if I
don't trade Queens I feel like I've got
to go all the way back and that's not
inspiring because then the Brooks were
connected and now the works are no
longer connected
classical rules yeah and the night's not
jumping so I feel like whether he likes
it or not Hikaru is just going to have
to allow the trade of queens and play
Knight F4
is time a factor yet not really Wesley
has around seven minutes and 13 seconds
whereas Hikaru Nakamura has just under
nine and a half minutes right I mean
these guys are still taking their time
exactly but once again that's something
we've seen in this particular match just
Hikaru getting a big time advantage and
then losing it towards the end of the
game right
Queen takes G4 is an option perhaps you
might even want to go back to F6 right
somehow as black I don't want to go
Queen G4 hg4 I just
I just feel that those you don't like
those zombies those double pawns I feel
are actually better
than
H3 G2 so and yeah he didn't trade I was
thinking Knight F4 but his choice of
Rook ae8 makes perfect sense as well
just can you try it right now since you
already set up the Rooks on the e-file
getting ready to open up the e-file with
uh it takes D4 can I sidestep that with
D5
a sidestep that with D5 why not it's
deaf
you are going to go with website
Trembling Hands my Rook might get Knight
F Knight F5 how is that
how are we feeling about this position
again I'm trying I'm getting a little
bit concerned that this bishop C1 is
going to be more effective than sure
this is one but Bishop to C1
sorry Joby yeah and I was just wondering
whether you had Queen takes Queen
followed by
yeah followed by um
Bishop C1 but no you don't or just
cementing the Knight yeah yeah no I sort
of want to force you to take on G4 yeah
so that I can cement that Knight on F5
with the age Pawn Fair that's fair yeah
Rook D1 okay but I was thinking
if does black want to play Sorry Rook 81
on the board yeah and what I was
wondering is about FCC Queen taste Queen
just a kind of a trade let's do it and
then now Pawn takes porn yeah yeah okay
let's do it and now D5
okay so the question you're asking is if
I play the move E5 you're trying to
undermine me with F6 absolutely I see
okay
but you don't have F4
so that might be a problem
well he's going for it he's taking it
asked and answered right
the players play like this because I'm
thinking either I'm playing 20 whatever
or 3 000 please I mean give yourself a
little credit oh they are
making natural but perhaps imprecise
moves okay so here's the question once
again if we play the move
F the E5 pardon me and you play F6 uh
who's undermining whom and uh for the
moment
right this pin is very very nasty I
think it was just better now after F7 F6
so Arthur D5 yeah well I don't know if
he's going to go E5 which is I just
played the move King F1 saying I invite
you to take I want to play D5
and if you drop your Rook back to E7
then I say hello to my little friend
that's right I'd have five at night
takes G7 so perhaps you have to get
ready for that with the move F6 first
ah
but that means
go for it yes can I win a pawn you
you've got a fork actually you change
everything I get the Knight to F4 and
he's done that F7 F6 move
has Hikaru
again
F3 again inviting you to take on e4 and
I like that move D5 a moment ago it
seemed to just open up my radiant Bishop
um
F3 I will go C6 it's all about
maintaining the tension F3 by the way I
think C6 in fact has a hidden threat
Bishop to B8 gotcha well we do see F3 on
the board you set the tension is
striking but
I I think I can just make a draw can't I
play E4 takes D5 and make a draw perhaps
this is what Wesley should go for yes
sorry I just have to refresh to keep my
board updated he's done it I think he's
going for it putting the brakes yeah
Wesley is incredibly practical
Jovi we're we're taking one step closer
and closer to your arm again
this 2023 uh American Cup has brought us
so much uh Thrills and Spills uh if it
goes to Armageddon that would just be
mind-blowing it would be wonderful I
think it would be a nice fitting but I
have to say
the way of Armageddon there is the
playoff yes that stands in the way we
saw how dominant Hikaru was in that
earlier matchup number two player in the
world and Blitz number 19 for Wesley in
Blitz and you're absolutely right that
that was a big diff yeah that was where
Hikaru one two zero and he he looked
like he was
he was a player there here any I I heard
you about your Bishop B8 trickies
anything to be said for Rook C1 uh
threatening
something something well I don't know
I'm not going to fall for it I'm not
going to play Bishop B8 after on C1 but
right it makes a lot of sense right not
only Rook C8 but also Rook C7 is a
pretty serious threat so yeah most
likely after Rook C1 I have to go Rook
C6 which
kind of invites me to change the pond
structure maybe a little bit in my favor
okay let's take you think because uh
I'm not sure if the C6 yeah and he's
played Rook C1 I'm not sure if the C6
Pawn
is better than the pawn on B7 Jovi I
think it's super important to control
the range of the white knights in this
type of situation and go Bishop B8 I I'd
agree with you wholeheartedly move the
king and just keep that Knight at Bay
move the king than play the move Knight
to E7
he's done it Rook C6 that feels safe
this is the current position on the
board as he didn't want to see this Rook
coming either to the C7 or the C8 Square
so he's offered the trade of Rooks
and
that means I've got a trade Rooks and
put my knight on C5 how I get the knight
from G3 to C5 that's going to be a tall
order
hmm well you can you can go Brook take
C6 92. well 91 93.
he's played 99
F5 okay so he's on his way towards C5
uh he just didn't he didn't do it with
the trade of Rooks a moment ago I was I
was I was bringing the Beast I bringing
the B7 Pawn to C6 trading changed the
structure uh two times yep so uh Wesley
is just over three and a half minutes
for Hikaru he's lots and lots of times
he's six and a half minutes you I mean
talk about the trend the trend has been
the same I mean almost a two to one time
advantage
I want to say six minutes from now there
are one one minute piece
it's really strange how the clock times
end up evening out king F7
so if you take and you try to venture
with the Knight on
D6
that's not going to lead too much right
so let's just take a look check
and Knight here so my intention
had been to drop by Knight in C5
virtually forcing you to capture and I
don't want to do it when it's easy for
you to
to handle everything that I I'm
attempting here
am I getting anything or am I
I don't see becoming worse I really
don't see it because once you put Knight
C5 I will take that with my bishop and
then I feel like it will be a
bad bishop or at least not as proficient
Bishop versus a good knight that's going
to start roaming around your
your setup Jovi how about you would you
be heading
be fine to to D6 and C5 yourself well I
like this move
I like this move too
you know you can't step away with the
Rook so obviously you have to make the
trade right
Trade It Up
in this case the move Knight to D6 check
definitely that's a fork so it turns out
that the problem is more vulnerable on
B7 than on C6 I think you should think
on B5 I was going to ask you you want
and now if you take can you throw it in
the Swish and sick all the time
our producer Tommy he likes the zook's
lungs and his Visions he feels like he's
a player when he can get that in but
you're forced to take yeah here
and well did you your night was actually
it was quite good
kind of uh so the answer is no and uh
Wesley said absolutely not moving that
night no I I I've got my D6 in reserve
and if you defend against the fork maybe
I can try to induce you to make a trade
on my term and you have questions to
answer with black pieces so for instance
like can come to E3 the white king
should start walking towards the center
yep but I see uh I see uh yeah but also
the night the night on G6 is tied to the
defense of the f8 square
has Wesley hogtied
Hikaru a bit especially if you could get
in G3 just a little bit just a little
bit just a little bit there's some
pressure okay there's definitely some
pressure and again let's try to get out
of this pressure this is the current
position with Wesley eyeballing 96 now
at the moment Knight D6 is not that big
a threat because D4 is hanging Bishop
maybe Knight E7
Knight f8 I was about to say I want to
do
to to
encourage the move Knight
d64. wait a minute do I have a bishop A3
sighting in the position right now if
you take on D4 I go Knight F5 and you
lose a piece
B7 okay Knight takes B7 I I missed the
pre-significant I respect the Trap that
you were okay I mean if I were to look
at this and this if I were white
dangerous than this I would be looking
at trading off Bishops
or would you like Bishop here
King E2
your kings are ready to be working right
yeah King's a fighting peace and you
know what the problem is and this is a
nice little trick which pay three don't
go 97. why because of 98. oh my oh my
goodness what a beautiful trap don't go
97. oh he's reaching for the night 96
yeah memorable words of Larry
Christensen I'll get you from behind
yes yes that's it that's game over so
Knight G6 was uh was the move okay
Knight to D6 that night is going to E8
we have Knight is still white white
feels like he's the one dictating
definitely for choice in this position
you have Wesley Is Amazing by the way
you have this interesting move Bishop to
B2
Bishop to force some trades finally
Force some trades you've been gunning
for these trades for a long time wow
Bishop to B2 that was not the I'm
looking at Knight F4 95 do something get
your pieces out of their little hold up
in their boxes but Knight F5 by the way
is on White's agenda pay attention
that's what I'm worried about I found
your move Bishop V2 wow that's a heads
up move that's a good good good move and
that's why he had to start with the move
Bishop to A3 first okay but I was always
told that when there are pawns on both
flanks the bishop is supposed to be
superior it did not play Bishop takes B2
by the way
Bishop to A3 we might see a repetition
or will Wesley try to play for victory
well it's always very practical to
repeat the position twice
and then
that's decision time okay if you go back
to A3 Bishop B2 will be a three-time
repetition yep
decided to play a night ending
and B6 and that's a move B6 is that the
move yes it is definitely a move and
should do uh Hikaru can now finally this
is the first time Hikaru gets a chance
to breathe he can play 95. and bring his
Knight into play finally but you're
gonna drop the G7 Pawn I'll I'll I'm
trying to trade
the G7 so what we're talking about uh so
everybody joins us in the conversation
95 B7
King C7 and what Jovi is saying is she's
going to spear
Pawn on G7 three versus three and I was
going to put my faith and trust blindly
into my passer I go King C6 D4 King C5
and try to escort the pawn up the board
Wesley is actually support for choice
because there's nothing preventing him
from doing this plans so he can first of
all improve the king
true well after Knight to E5 you have a
threat yeah finally 95 does threaten as
you were about to say King takes
but
Karu has an extraordinary sense of
danger
and he is just double and treble
checking that he's not going to be laid
astray if he plays the move 95. quick
question for you Jovi do you like that
line that we yeah well he's going for it
and now bringing the king don't play
Knight G7 don't play 96 immediately
Hikaru looked like ooh I've missed
something
let's go G5 or G6 now yeah but now the
king will walk today D4 this is what I
was saying I'm going to put my
now of course I can make a draw that's
not the question the question is should
I be playing
for more with Knight E6 maybe I can even
start with King E2 right and he's doing
based on it
so that begs the question why didn't he
start with King E2
it's Blitz
that's exactly what it is G5 or G6 okay
now Hikaru says look I gave you your
chance to go fishing after that G7 Pawn
I'm not going to let you have every
opportunity
how's the engine if you say triple zeros
I'm gonna have Tom come over and
close to that yes
close to that close to uh triple zeros
maybe 0.1 but if you let everything
I mean my feeling is white should be
better but okay proving it is a material
is so limited though right that's the
problem but well but aren't you also
limited exactly at some point you will
have to give the B7 Paul you're stuck
for choice you gotta play like King B8
is as a move you don't want to move your
knight and you don't want to move your
Pawns
uh that is a shocking move for me
because it means I get to play f4 on a
good day
though when the pawn was on G4 the move
F4 would always have been met by Knight
takes G4 so H5 I think really helped
Wesley whether it's meaningful that's a
different question
hmm
Curry's getting some chances now hakara
is getting chances really sorry not he
caught Wesley Wesley but what if you go
by G6 I think that was a very good move
because F4 may have been a tickle you
don't want you didn't want perhaps
saying that hey look you need to play 96
now
if you don't I get my knight to F4 and
right that will be able I will be able
to support my own Pawn right more
promotion any ideas like G3 presumably
will be met through H4 exactly trading
off more pawns right Traders that's one
once we trade the H for the G Pawn
that's going to be a draw easy draw
because I will always have in reserve
the sacrifice of the night for the pawn
on F3 and then just use the d-pawn as a
decoy by the way more and more as I
watch these two Gladiators sit down to
do battle the more I I say these really
really you need top players playing in
their Prime because we're seeing some
really great contests here I mean the
quality of their moves has been
extraordinary despite whatever Tempo
there they play they seem to come up
with some incredibly good and
sophisticated play King F2
H4 just stopping King G3 ideas don't let
the knight jump to F4 unattended go for
96 it's time it's time it's time to call
it a day
well call it a game call it the game and
then have to defend he has the option
he's got the option of winning the F6
Pawn Yeah I was thinking the same but
you know what
a D4 Pawn could be and he's gone for the
the D4 Pawn could be the one that
actually hurts you so this this looks
like the right or the right choice I
think this was the right choice and uh
Wesley with 30 seconds on the clock that
he's he's looking at King E4
uh King F5 ideas if he could navigate to
the FI Square he's still got
he's still got opportunity
and Hikaru says nope you can well King
F5 King G4 let's go
come on is this I think I'm going to
give you that pawn well wait a minute
wait a minute it's not that I think I'm
going to give you I'm taking
just a second put it in perspective can
the G4 King F5 Knight F5 I'm taking
that's okay no problem two versus one
two versus one will not be enough uh
really and Wesley despite the fact he
only has 10 seconds on his clock is
still the one pressing get the king to
G6
and Hikaru is shaking his head like
why are we here why am I here
okay well the thing is there was it
doesn't have much time but he can just
message build it up he's gonna he's
gonna be exactly King E3 King E4 and
that's gonna gain them 20 seconds maybe
20 maybe 30 seconds and before you know
it he's going to have a minute
Hikaru is going to be down to a minute
30 seconds any car is going to be a pawn
down and the chances of winning suddenly
start to look realistic and even if this
game ends in a draw from a psychological
point of view you've made that drop from
a position of power yeah that is Wesley
saw so he's going to be happy going into
the second ten plus five the moral
Victor
don't you feel terrible the fact that
you were suffering upon down
um
I understand it is drawn but I'm not
convinced it's very difficult either I
well I'm just having a look at the
at the table base which is now popped up
on my screen and I can see that
basically as long as black king stays
close to the F6 pawnish is going to be a
draw
okay
well more saliently for me the question
is where should I be defending the F6
Pawn from the E7 Square from the G7
square like should I be allowing White's
King to go to D5 to D6 to E7 or should I
be trying to stop the white king from
going to H5
and where have you
95 okay don't exchange
uh yes that would be that would be
disastrous an error
Knight D7 makes the most sense okay 97
G3 just
keeping the king at Bay
G3 let's give some checks Knight C5 I
think he's very instructive that Hikaru
just doesn't push the F5 Pawn even
though it is a draw I think it's
significantly makes the task much harder
because the king and Knight can surround
the pawn easier Knight C5 check get the
king get Knight to D3 whoa whoa from
that I thought he was going to go King
D4 but okay seven six and G3 that came
like the four a move or two late night
F4 check King E4 Knight E2 IG Knight E2
don't go 95.
anything but that one
95 would be a horror show 10 seconds
yeah Wesley on 10 seconds uh Hikari well
one minute and 10 seconds again you were
saying and I believe you can considering
F5 right now
yeah you were saying keep your King
close to the F6 pawn and I'm thinking if
I'm white if I could go King E6 King F7
and get in this move F4 I'm golden
I can't say I'm a big fan of allowing
that pawn to come to F4 I really like
the move Knight F4
it's still a draw like of course for
sure yeah we're still in the table based
draw
but anyway can you play a five right now
yeah you can that's one way to draw
another way to draw it just simply just
move the Knight I would be anywhere I'd
be so reluctant to play F5 because the
move King D6 followed by King E6 I like
this move this move has my attention
because
you know whenever you move your king
I've got Knight E4 as a way of tickling
and here we go this was my question
to E6 and E7
94. I play G4 G4 and give a check on
this uh go King E7 okay Knight H1
now I'm not happy because after F5
again you can go back to F2 and then
start giving checks that should be
enough right but you're getting down to
your last 20 seconds true
now your position gets a bit more
passive
I don't know I'm not a big fan of
watching oh and I can see that the path
is narrowing on the table base and now
it's still a draw but um
King E7 King f8 I mean 95 what do you do
after 95 yes 95 probably four three
she almost pulled an arena crush and and
zoned that zoned out and let his time
tick away but he's got the 11 seconds
now perhaps Knight to E4 G4 now you have
Knight F2 right and F5 just in the nick
of time This is Gonna Change
G5 lynches he found it he found it right
six seconds four seconds
very nice there we go
[Laughter]
oh
wow oh there's nothing between them yeah
the Playoff starts off with a draw and
now the players will play another game
whoever wins that will walk away with
the American Cup title
wow okay great stuff another very very
hard well-fought game uh makes a draw
and uh
and uh 50 000 for the winner 35
000 for the runner-up and already at ten
thousand dollars
in hikaru's pocket so he has the
potential of winning 60
000 and Wesley has the potential of
winning 50 000. so uh everything to play
for uh
what do you say Christian just a very
well balanced game a little big
opportunity for Wesley there was a big
opportunity right here right now when he
took on B7 which makes the most sense
obviously especially with only two
minutes on the clock but Bishop to A3 if
he would have stopped and thought about
this idea
very difficult position for black
because right now the only move one of
the only moves not to be completely
losing is King to D7 you cannot take on
D4 that's going to allow a double attack
Knight F5 attack the bishop on D4 the
Knight on f8 you're going to lose a
piece game over so what you can do is go
King to this what are the chances that
Hikaru would have just given up the pawn
like this with the move King to D7 in
this
uh situation Knight to D7 this just
loses right Bishop takes D4 Knight to d8
King to E5 Knight to C6 game over you
cannot do that so this is the only path
for equality into D7 take on B7 Knight
to E6 allow Knight to C5
allow the two passers like this and now
hook them up with the move Knight to D4
and maybe you will be surviving this
after B6 King to C6 set up some sort of
a blockade this is not easy stuff guys
no because this bishop can go back to B2
it's not that easy to take on C5 the
b-pawn is going to run down the board so
this would have been a real chance for
Wesley so to take the full point home he
did not find it and after that Hikaru
defended very accurately but still
very little to separate these two
players so far guys wow uh what an
opportunity I and I think uh Christian
pointed it out at the time and you can't
blame Wesley Knight takes B7 that also
did net him eventually an extra Pawn but
it wasn't enough no I know and that now
we're going to move on to the next game
where Hikaru has the white pieces right
and then bearing in mind what happened
in the earlier playoff yes in the time
when they were fighting for the
championship
and there you know Hikaru was dominant
when it came to the blitz you know
completely you know it felt like Wesley
was a child and that doesn't really ever
happen so in light of that I'm thinking
that Hikaru is going to just force a
draw very early on no need to struggle
and then get to
he's been seated at the ward uh well
before the game and he's really putting
everything all of his efforts in it
and we're getting closer and closer to a
possible Armageddon yeah we are
um because there is still one more rapid
playoff game to be played the players
will have 10 minutes plus a five second
increment hikara begins with the white
pieces Wesley has the black and if that
match so if that game ends in a draw
then we will see the blitz play off yeah
and we don't know what's going to happen
but I think it's a very very good time
to give a shout out to the St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center the
Staffing here has just been fantastic
everybody makes us all feel welcome and
uh we we're gonna name names
except for the fact that they are off
and running and a repeat of their
earlier game with Knight F3 and E3 now
remember in that game it was like Knight
F6 and B3 and that whole C5 sequence
Wesley well he got the isolated Queen
Pawn
and um
maybe it's time to repeat it I mean he
didn't have any problems in the first
game yeah he made I want to say a
comfortable draw and he's repeating that
entire line
because uh Rook C1 that's the wrinkle
the the previously it was D4
and Knight E4 is what I want to say
um and uh by the way Hikaru
choosing a very combative line in the
sense of the pieces are still
in all the pieces are still on the board
and if you wanted a drawer like I was
predicting completely wrong you would
have just simply gone into that famous
Berlin or yes
or repeated entirely their first game
exactly by the way does this allow I'm
sure we're still in theory does this
allow the move d5d4 because let's face
it the move d2d4 did stop
and Wesley's having a a think about it
I mean if you take
take Knight B5 it's like you know what
you're gonna win this Pawn but it's
going to be an awkward thing your king
is still stuck in the center of the
board
um
I don't know if it's Theory or not this
uh no not Theory at all the D5 no one
has ever played for example everyone has
kind of gone played
I mean this is this is everybody's go-to
move and it was Wesley's Pardon Me
hikaru's original but D4 so let's try to
decide and guess what he's going for it
oh wow instantly night A4 and yeah not
even capturing capturing going for but
Knight A4
I think we're off the beaten path here
Chris we are indeed yes no Rook C1 was
the novelty and the idea is clear you
want to Target that pawn on C5 before
black manages to develop her his pieces
on the queen side Bishop E6 Rook to C8
Defender opponent C5
I apologize but I just like Black's
position okay I take on E3 with the
maybe I'll take with the F Pawn okay
let's play B7 B6 and I question you
why is your night on me irrelevant
you don't mind I don't mind okay
you're not even going to be pretty
aggressive well I I know you as a the
hyper aggressive right
co-commentator uh but I mean no and now
my age yeah that guy is just forget
about it forget about it don't stress
about those bad pieces and then go
Knight F5 and then
night's on the rim yeah come on help me
out of here night's on the river dim and
you're putting both nights uh this is
modern chess right here what is this
what is this uh British chest at its
best come on come on
come here
the the the
colonists here will uh capture on E3 as
has Wesley
takes E3 very combative now B7 B6 was my
first move just because you know I like
my pawns I want to be in Shadow also I
could play Knight to D7 but B7 B6
well the players are following our
analysis there should be seven castles
now if I really thought that this was a
threat uh I would stop maybe and play
for 94 and Bishop F6 but I'm not afraid
I will play Knight C6
let's let's go Knight H4 let's go
night
um
to be for
I
I'll be I'll be computer like and if I
go full on
hacker mode
Knight F5 and I said take that pawn on
A2 I don't care
and then I'm going to play my Rook to
see
and guess what life he said your night's
not going even to the H4 Square I'm
gonna go Knight E4 Knight D5 sorry wait
a minute hold on he played here Bishop
E2 and he played Knight to D5
not even 94.
okay Knight to D5 castles on the board
once again if anything even if Hikaru
didn't get a better position objectively
out of the opening yeah he made his
opponent think Wesley right now took six
minutes and 30 seconds against 10
minutes and 30 seconds Knight C6 well
again I'm I like black I like the the
pawn structure for black why think of
the pawn Islands well it has three Pond
Islands black has two Pond Islands
in particular I don't like the Knight on
A4 and as you said stop stressing uh but
don't let me back in yeah but the moment
you get back into play I've been waiting
for this opportunity to turn the tables
on you and pin your knight to your
Bishop so I have to wait for it okay
right what about Queen to E1 let's try
to play Queen E1 or Grand Prix right
okay I like it Christian Bishop B7 here
we go Queenie one on the board desperate
times come call for desperate measures I
love that especially Queen E1 Bishop
six right yeah Maiden one neutralize
tension
and if I take what are you going to
recapture with I'll pause because I'm
not really sure what the big
um uh discovered attack is going to look
like I'm not I mean let's go for it
Knight G5 see if that leads anywhere
um I don't know it's centralized pieces
Queen E5 Queen E5 what did he do he did
something no so he's he played Bishop
okay Bishop Bishop B7 so yeah keep the
pieces centralized and again
I I keep referring to my one trump card
right because
again this is the current position this
is where we expected Bishop F6 he played
and in case of a trade I was recapturing
with the queen Knight takes also
perfectly viable but Queen takes could
you also give very feisty and instead of
going Bishop takes F6 I actually go
E4 no Bishop F6 on the board E4
that would have been feisty yeah okay
you're in my porn structure yeah well
done just like you recommended right now
Wesley saw passes and Ponders yeah
because I can understand why you might
find Knight takes the uh S6 attractive
but still Queen takes F6 bring no 96 F6
okay and Knight C3
okay well there goes my uh
the one thing I was berating
about hikaru's position was his off-site
night at least he has in fact uh cured
it for the moment
I don't like the fact that this queen is
so annoying on the G3 Square
and I would love to
how do you say nudge it away something
like Queen B8
uh
using the Ivanka Golden Rule of trading
Queens whenever I feel my king is under
attack would have my attention 94. now
that's
aggressive it is you know the night is
threatening to come into D3 just to
State the obvious
love that okay but what if I start
looking at that F5 Square
finally you don't seem to have any
Defenders around your king anymore or at
least not as many like each four let's
try it out Knight H4 why not in for a
penny in for around 94 let's go
I probably have to take that and Bishop
takes
so I'm ready to defend excellent
Bishop C4
ship C4
he's giving me pawns I am he's making my
life happy I am I am take it come on
take it okay
Knight E5 sorry uh
well he's also a shooting boards uh he
wants to give a pawn but he he's gonna
get a night in return so I don't even
think about playing Queen takes D2 why I
think about it really where it takes
no Queen takes Rook
yes yes yes
I think about it uh after Knight E5 uh
Wesley responded quickly did he what
movie did no was he still he hasn't
because yeah I think about it what what
what's wrong with Queen takes D2
ugh
Rook D1 fd1 yes and then Queen B2 is
forced Knight C4
um
that is embarrassing very embarrassing
it won't be the first or the last time I
get caught with my hand in the cookie
jar I gotta tell you I'll warn you you
give me your pawns I'll take them even
at the cost of my queen guys yes four
minutes for Wesley eight minutes for
Hikaru and a very difficult position I
have to say for Western with that f file
opening up right now the bishop coming
to C4 so much pressure in the position
against Knight on F6 and the pawn on F7
he takes it what things they do no Queen
takes the Rook fd1 finishes the game on
the spot Hikaru
oh my God Wesley missed it and he's in a
resignation position right now oh my
word just and there's the game the match
set and title for Grandmaster Hikaru
nakawa right now that shake of the head
and Wesley said oh my well I mean
sometimes you just have a blind spot and
that's it you if you don't see why I
can't take the pawn look at him look at
let's pan out on Wesley he's yeah he
knows it he knows just this is over he
just lost the title game
Replay that in slow motion because here
we we've just made the realization that
Queen takes D2 loses the queen gets
trapped to an Rook D1 Knight C4 Wesley
didn't see it he and those retreating
moves Knight E5 to C4
and Wesley's sitting there going oh
oh
inikaru I can't believe is good fortune
right so Queen B2 Knight C4 is there any
way I think absolutely not I can get
something well you can give up the queen
for The Rook but well I'm trying
21.3 Queen B2 Knight C4 I'm trying I
nobody ever won a game that's it okay
Nakamura is American Cup champion wow
wow what a finale
and because they've been playing such
great chess it's remarkable that it was
the bad blunder that decided the outcome
but our congratulations nonetheless to
Hikaru Nakamura as he Pockets a very
smooth fifty thousand dollars as well as
the honor
of the American Cup champion
congratulations to Cairo
and oh
what a devastating end I know Wesley
says Quest something was about I was
looking forward to the three plus twos
as well I didn't see this is happening
but I have to say you know hats off to
Hikaru because you know he was
yeah has taken his chances when it
mattered he's also played in a very
aggressive style he's entertained us all
you know very worthy champion and that's
what it comes down to right in these
final moments it's all about resiliency
right and the nerves and we've seen the
nerves play out for Wesley so in this
one and even in the game that ikaru just
drew I mean I know it was it looked like
it was very easy and he could make a
draw upon down
lots of players do panic and well he as
you say he kept his resiliency uh well
well done oh lots of players would
easily crumble exactly with so much
pressure in that end game even the
Knight 2 versus night one that's what it
means either yeah it's not super super
simple but uh Hikaru defended it very
very well and uh wow
the players are still sharing
Impressions about the game
there is the proud father of Hikaru
Sunil Sunil mantri on the right
stepfather to Hikaru I came for the
finals uh it did tsuno and glad he did
and with good fortune
now let's go uh oh
first of all let's go through the
finishing finishers start with the open
Champions uh if you don't mind
definitely first up is Sam Sabian who
tied for seventh place and netted 12
000. thousand dollars and then we move
on to Ray Robson also tying for seventh
place
and then we had Sam shankland who
actually tied to a fifth place and
netted a very healthy sum of eighteen
thousand dollars and he was joined in
joint fifth alongside Fabiano Carona the
defending Champion got knocked out in an
amazing match with levona Romeo
and then we had lenia Dominguez
Dominguez in fourth place and walking
away with twenty thousand dollars he was
runner-up in the elimination bracket yes
and then we saw levonne aronian and he
had finished in third place with twenty
five thousand dollars losing to Wesley
so
and in second place well a worthy
Contender he made some combat victories
and he entertained us all with sparkling
chess it was Wesley so who walked away
with 35
000 dollars
but Arch American Cup champion was none
other than Hikaru Nakamura who netted 50
000 and a 10 000 Champion bracket winner
bonus not about a couple of weeks let's
go through the ladies and all of our
contenders beginning with culture yes
sir she's tired for seventh place and
walked away six thousand dollars
alongside
and also time for seventh place and then
we move on to
tartev abrahamian who walked away with
nine thousand dollars and finished in
fifth place
alongside a two-step for cashion who
also won a anatomski that was eliminated
exactly and then we had Beckham talking
to Nova she finished in fourth place
with ten thousand dollars very very fine
performance and the third place was Naji
paikitsa twelve thousand dollars and in
second place we had a 13 year old Alice
Lee watch out for that name she is going
places she finished with 18
000 dollars
and the American Cup 2023 Champion is
Arena Crush walking away with twenty
five thousand dollars and five thousand
dollars for winning the championship
racket a repeat winner for sure but she
was at least dinged Alice did get in one
victory
and and in the American Cup Blitz event
it was Fabiano caruana who walked away
with first place and all the honor and
all the glory alongside five thousand
dollars then we're gonna stop calling
him a poor Blitz player if he keeps this
kind of Blitz up uh he's gonna that that
reputation is gone
but I wanted to say thank you and big
shout outs to everybody at the St Louis
chess club in Scholastic absolutely uh
tell tell the people uh call out some
names yes the most deserving and uh
first of all you know this tournament
would not have happened if it had not
been for Rex and Dr Jeannie singfield
it's a massive thank you to them and
also to Joy Bray Tony Rich crisper the
Alberta Judith Chateau Ray also an
Arbiter Rebecca Buffington Leonard
events coordinator she does great I mean
the thank you Rebecca for all of the
jack kit swag and food that is sorry yes
definitely I'm gonna get an extra sushi
nice thinking Emily Trask Ryan Chester
all the rest of the Saint Louis chess
club who do incredible job we have to
say and Randy and Spectrum as well as
Kevin and everyone at Silverback and of
course last but not least I would give
like to give my deepest thanks to
everyone who watched the show and
supported the show joined in the farm
sent us your tweets and just enjoy chess
every move of the way you guys have made
it incredibly special for all of us and
I've got to say big big shout outs thank
you so much to the World Chess Hall of
Fame for their hosting of the event
Shannon Bailey Emily uh just you guys we
come in every day they make a smile
thank you for all of that
and we have our champion in studio with
Christian
Hikaru so many hours so many games spent
in the presence of this worthy opponent
Wesley so sum up your feelings right now
after this incredible match I mean it
was it's crazy I think this match I mean
frankly the way that I look at it is
really came down to who won that first
match on the Champions bracket in terms
of who who's likely going to win I mean
we're so evenly matched um you know
Wesley won yesterday I won today I mean
I would I would say that I think
actually today Wesley was clearly the
better player I was not very sharp um
even though maybe the games don't look
so bad my calculation was horrible
especially in this uh first 10 minute
game this third game we played today I
mean I thought it was just much better
and the next thing I know I'm just like
losing I mean I don't know if I'm
actually losing but I'm much worse than
a night end game
um and so I think my calculation wasn't
great I think Wesley was just better but
fortunately the final game had this
little little silly idea with Knight A4
and you know I was kind of hoping Wesley
would make a blunder because after
playing so many games it's nice to you
know have a simple simple win there so
it's tough um but I mean I think either
of us could have won it just ended up
being me though at the end of the day
you surely wanted to end uh the matches
and the championship yesterday
unfortunately for you you weren't able
to do so did you tell yourself at night
trying to get ready for this matchup
um well I mean I was I was very very
upset with myself uh without specifying
there's there's some other stuff going
on that's significantly bigger than this
tournament that I'll be announcing in
the very near future that I've been
dealing with throughout the event
um so I was pretty upset because if I
had the free day today I could have
taken care of some other stuff um but
but really it's just sort of I had to
reset because coming into this
tournament I had one goal which is
basically you know don't make a fool of
myself and don't lose like 10 or 15
rating points um In classical that was
my only goal I know a lot of people
think that I'm just like showboating or
making stuff up but that was really the
only goal I had in mind and so you know
when I looked looked at yesterday having
lost that match I accomplished the first
goal which was not to lose a ton of
points and then it's sort of if you
could have told me I'd be playing a
tiebreaker against Wesley for for all
the marbles um today I would be happy
with that and so that's really just the
attitude I had but even beyond that I
mean last night you know I actually
didn't really look at chess I kind of I
went I didn't do a recap I didn't look
at chess I went out had some beers
played some pool and uh just forgot
about everything and it seemed to work
out so you just I just tried to get past
as quickly as I could it definitely did
now let's talk about this final moment
in this game you played this move Knight
to E5
did you think that he could ever touch
that pawn on D2 in your while no no no I
mean I I saw that it was just a blunder
so Rook d1904 instantly but the thing is
it's weird because before the and this
is one of the dangers of using computers
if you don't have all day is this Knight
E4 move which I played on move number
nine I deviated from the earlier game
with this whole work C1 Knight A4
um I had looked at quite a few different
moves here that were interesting like
Queen A5 and B6 and other things and
then as Wesley was thinking for like a
minute I'm like well why can't I just
take on E3 and play B6 like he did in
the game so I mean it's like I got the
time Edge but then when he did this I'm
like well what am I doing I mean I guess
I should have taken with a d-pawn but
after playing for so long it's like why
do I want to play one of these end games
I mean it's just I I felt like I should
take my chances
um I don't think what I did was great I
think I think for Wesley he just uh he
just missed well we both miss it of
course but after in in these positions
where I go like
um where I go Knight C3 I think he is 97
here at some point maybe not right away
but I thought he had 97 and Knight G6
because the way that I felt about the
position is the only plan I had was to
put like Knight H4 Knight F5 or like 95
95 it feels like I should have something
but if black gets those two nights on F6
and G6 I don't even know I mean where is
my Center play I can't really play D4
he's like I can't go E4 so I don't know
if you've done this I think there's a
good chance Wesley would have been the
winner actually but fortunately he
played Knight before I got 95 and then
when he was singing for a while and like
right before he played smooth I think he
he like looked up and looked at me and
that's when I was like I had a feeling
he was actually going to play play Queen
takes D2
um and I mean after a long day it's I
mean it's a tragedy for the match on
this way of course but it's you know
it's what it is long tournament uh long
day as well at the office guys join the
conversation really I I just have to say
uh congratulations uh I thought you just
played terrific throughout you're very
very deserving winner winner I I know
you call yourself an amateur Hikaru but
you're beating the best Pros that
America could put up against you yeah I
mean it's it's like um it's funny
because I never like if you go back even
like three years I mean I never do this
but actually when I've won some of these
matches like you know I like when I beat
Wesley here I said sorry because I mean
obviously for him winning this term
would mean a lot more than it means
means for me and I mean not trying to
diminish it in any way but I mean I do
feel bad on some level because like I'm
just here trying not to make a fool of
myself and and then I find a way to win
so
yeah I mean it's it's not going to
change anything though let's put it that
way I know some people think that it
might change I might have some Grand
Ambitions I'll play some tournaments
maybe I'll qualify for the candidates
maybe I won't who cares
so what actually is next for you Hikari
yeah so I mean also you know another
thing I have to say is I mean I have to
give a lot of credit to Wesley because
playing like eight days in a row was was
very hard well I mean I know I had the
one rest they were playing like eight
days in a rows very hard but Wesley had
to play I think nine days in a row if
I'm not mistaken so you play every day
here I think he played in Germany played
the Armageddon he played the previous
classical then he played Tata steel so I
mean Wesley's been playing non-stop for
two or three months now and I mean
considering considering how tired I'm
sure he had to be his play was really
really good so I mean a lot a lot of
props uh to Wesley for that of course
for for all of us we now have the great
joy of going and playing this uh chess
Champions Tour event in like four days
or something I don't know it's very very
soon
um so I'll be playing that and then
after that I think finally things slowed
down and I have this event in Norway
Norway chest which will be at the end of
May maybe there was a Champions Tour
event before that but that's what I have
coming up so it'll be exciting one final
question Wesley did mentioned yesterday
that you stream 24 7 and yet you still
play at the Elite level how do you do it
how do I do it I mean it's very
difficult I think you know I think one
of the the most important things is that
because I'm not studying every day I'm
not playing all these tournaments it's
not as much of a grind I think when you
go from tournament to tournament and you
play the same players like say you know
say in four days I have to play Wesley
well I mean maybe maybe I will actually
in this in this chess Champions Tour
event but when you have to play the same
players you look at these same openings
over and over and over again for for
weeks if not months on end I think that
chess isn't so fresh you start to get
like bored you start to get annoyed I
mean there are a lot of different
emotions that you have and so for me I
think I'm able to sort of look at it as
like trying to play interesting chess
trying to have some fun and really
enjoying it because I know that I'm not
going to get an opportunity anytime soon
to play play play over the board chess
so that's just the mindset I have I mean
it seems to work for me
um but you know also beyond that I think
it's just that I am sort of playing with
house money all the time and um I'm just
just trying to come with ideas trying to
surprise my opponents I think there's a
lot more on the line for them there's
much more pressure than there is for me
so I've just find a way to make it work
but it's but you know it's not easy it's
not easy at all congratulations you are
the 2023 American Cup champion thank you
guys and again congratulations wow what
a champion so it comes to this all good
things must end uh Jovi uh once again I
really I appreciate uh working with you
and Christian it is it's a Love Fest yes
but it's but it's been really really
amazing
I have to say again with Christian yeah
it hasn't felt like the teasing has been
an excellent level it's just been
enjoying the chess and enjoying what the
players have provided for us truly it's
just been wonderful and again I'd also
like to thank everyone watching at home
you know we really couldn't have done it
without you keep on playing chess and I
do believe of course that we've got our
runner-up in studio with uh Christian to
share his thoughts Christian Wesley
first of all all commiserations this is
not the way you wanted to see this match
and what are your feelings right now
well first of all big congratulations to
Hikaru I think it's a well-deserved
Victory I mean we both made mistakes I
mean after such long matches but uh I
think he's an extremely strong player on
all time controls and in crucial moments
especially in Blitz he had a big
advantage so yeah big congratulations
Sam I'm not really
that sad I mean I think I fought hard I
think I was playing very decently I had
some chances here in there
uh but the end of the day that's what
Jeff is about and Jeff gotta keep trying
I mean it's unfortunate that you had to
end like this with my queen getting
trapped
but at that point I was already kind of
tired from playing day in day out and I
was pushing but
uh really it was today we really was a
coin toss anything could have happened
but if it gets to the Armageddon I think
he carries a big Advantage so I had to
find a way to you know you've took uh
hikar all the way until the final
stretch and I have to say you were
putting a lot of pressure in that 10
plus five section at least that's how it
felt for us in all three matches even in
this one yeah the first game with the
white pieces that end game uh Bishop
Knight and a few pawns but it still felt
like you have a lot of pressure did you
feel like you were winning at anything
oh that the first and the first ten plus
five game today yes no I don't think I
was ever winning I think he made some
mistakes he had a very good preparation
in the opening but I don't think I was
ever winning like it was making mistakes
maybe there was this moment right here I
didn't see any wind at all when you
played Knight takes B7 you had this move
Bishop to A3 which puts a lot of
pressure on him if he takes then you go
Knight to five Knight D7 you take on the
98.
Oh I thought I missed after King D7
Knight b796 I missed I have 99 C5 it's
still not over by the way he has to take
and then go Knight to D4 but this is not
going to be an easy defense for oh also
after Bishop A3 yes
I thought
G6 right G6 Knight to F5 yeah I missed
also this Knight F5 King F7 Bishop C5
yeah I think I saw something like this I
thought he could take on C5 Bishop B8
Bishop D6 Bishop A7 and then the bishop
get strap yeah Bishop A3 yeah but the
thing I was already quite happy with the
position like the way I was out playing
him
and I just didn't see Bishop yeah I
didn't uh
I thought yeah Bishop a there I was
thinking D7 and Knight gets to E6 and
then I stopped yeah yeah not an easy
move to assess especially with like two
minutes and 30 seconds yeah one thing I
must say is
a much better time management than me in
in all formats so uh in the beginning
it's not a big deal because when you get
a good position it doesn't matter but in
the end it matters when I had a few
seconds
guys yeah first of all Wesley thank you
very much indeed I I know it's been a
challenging uh grueling start to the
year as you've been playing uh back to
back to back tournaments but uh your
your play here was really a joy to
behold very very much so and uh really I
I wanted to ask you about the format
because
this is the only tournament that uses
this double elimination format but as a
commentator
it's so much fun to call this this this
event would you like to see this format
being used for example for a US
championship
oh us championship for example well
that's very interesting I mean I
think the youth Championship has been
the same as I've been around Swiss
or last year was 13 but yes it has been
the same 11 around round robin for a
long time right other than a few
exceptions right uh
um
yeah it's hard to say I mean this
tournament was very exciting and the
American Cup is even stronger than the
US Championship because it's very
exclusive so it could very well work
um for me personally I kind of like this
double elimination format that way if
you lose you can always come back
and
um if you have an off day you can fight
hard the next day
and also it's become quite popular
recently online also in the Berlin
Armageddon series
so it could it could very well
uh
work for sure
but then No One's Gonna Break Fisher's
record
nine championships Jovi uh for our
runner-up Wesley is always good yeah now
I'd like to say congratulations Wesley
and
what is next for you you've been paying
a lot of chess
yeah now I have uh I have some break
well there's some online tournaments in
between the Champions Chester
but uh you probably be commentating that
right if I'm correct
will you be commentating
I'm going to Germany but yeah that one I
play Levon or onion in division one I
think it starts in a week or something
okay and then I have quite a long break
probably watch Hikaru play title Tuesday
and then and then after that
grantchester start actually I have a
very
tough schedule ahead of me and playing
in the Romania which is a classical
tournament and then I'm playing in
Poland which is wrapping Blitz and then
I'm playing in Norway chess
which is extremely strong with Magnus
Fierce yeah Hikaru Fabiano it's at there
so I have to prepare but um
I mean I'd like to
say to say thank you to all the people
who made this event possible I think
first of all to the St Louis jazz club
and then throw all three of you thanks
for thank you
to the referees especially Chris bird
and Judith satire they've been extremely
helpful and also to my mother who's
always encouraging me amongst many
others and again big congratulations to
Hikaru for well the third win and also
Irena I
I looked at her games here and she's
incredibly tough and she managed to beat
Alice Lee and come back Victory so
that's uh that's good for me I'm trying
to again focus on my classical chess so
um you know wrap it in Blitz is just I
mean it's good if I do well but trying
to play better chess Wesley
congratulations on an incredible
tournament yeah also congratulations to
Fabiano for winning today's place
last and last the last uh before we let
you say goodbye Wesley oh I'm a fake
yeah so it's your fault I love this last
game oh
thinking of you
yeah I looked at my club I was getting
low on the time and you took the pawn
yeah I did
I didn't keep playing you know shorter
time control so I thought either I win
or I lose
[Music]
but I wanted to I wanted the rumor on
the street just saying the rumor on the
street is that yesterday you had signed
up for the blitz not realizing you were
going to prolong the match is that true
that you were ready to play Blitz today
who told you I don't know but it was
just the rumor the rumor on the street
yeah I ran into my Comer on the street
and I was asking him where the blitz was
gonna be okay so you were ready to play
some Blitz if it came down to it right
yeah maybe
maybe it's not too late
Wesley you've got a lot a lot of fans uh
in the Chess World congratulations and
good luck on what sounds like a very
very tough schedule ahead for you yeah I
think because also Magnus is playing in
Romania in in Norway so okay
all right again congratulations and
again uh for us it was really great we
enjoyed everything about this event and
even Wesley said you know this format
could be used for a determination of a
national championship for those of you
in the fide audience uh consider if
consider changing the World Cup to a
double elimination I think that would be
a more enjoyable event just not to go
[Music]
it's in the past history
you can come back anytime
forget about it forget about it history
history it's a nice winning recipe just
choose the top dogs the winning recipe
choose the top dogs you heard it here
first again it was great fun thank you
make sure you come back to St Louis you
know it's a welcome coming Club here
will do and Christian final thoughts of
another uh eventful event what else to
say about this incredible matches this
incredible two tournaments I had a lot
of fun and I have to thank you guys for
putting on an incredible show helping me
around here you know the Synergy between
us has definitely been felt and I really
enjoyed my time with you guys also I
have to thank to the Saint Lucia's Club
Rex and geniusingfield and everybody
involved in this production I've had a
lot of fun absolutely
pleasure it's been wonderful thank you
so much for sharing your time with us
and hanging out tell everybody where you
do hang out and the St Louis chess club
did you a fair fair farewell
and that is it goodbye goodbye
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited